Oh, that's right.
No, no animation.
No waiting animation.
We out.
We out here.
All right.
The hoes are watching.
Yeah.
Altair, what was that catchphrase that you wanted to say
after that?
Suck it, nerds.
Oh, no.
He did not say that.
It was not nerds.
It was sucking something, but it wasn't nerds.
Suck it, noobs.
The hoes are watching.
All right.
Come on, Altair.
You know you want to say it.
It starts with a P. Pokemon.
Dang, of course he's into that.
You guys are trying to get me.
You guys are trying to get all my videos restricted, huh?
No, no, of course not.
Oh, no, we would never do that to you.
Because if your videos get restricted, our videos get
restricted too, because we're streaming with you.
Hey, mine gets restricted anyways.
It don't really matter.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
I got my Garfield video restricted because I sang a very
inappropriate song.
I sang a very inappropriate song as Garfield.
Garfield's thing's inappropriate songs?
Yeah, it was, yeah.
I thought inappropriate songs only existed like Rick and
Morty and South Park and shit for you.
Like, you know, I said I was rapping a very inappropriate
song.
What was it about?
Give us a context.
Why was it so inappropriate?
It was like, you know, Lonely Island.
You know, Lonely Island.
No, I just touched.
oh and it felt so good that was so good yeah so it was from
the lonely item it was very inappropriate and i did it as
garfield i mean come on that's a classic though no no it
wasn't that it was a lot worse it was a lot worse oh okay so
you didn't go with the classic you went with like an og yeah
yeah yeah an og son from snl hey guys hello everybody
welcome to battlefield field redsac um so the only one
person with the most experience is axel he's also going to
be the one with the no no no no no i am not experienced at
all the one with the most experience and he's gonna carry
both altera and i will be actually i expect high things from
you yeah expect so much from you axel now i'm gonna be
browsing twitter dude you y'all do you know what the You
were the one, you were like, I love Battlefield.
I love Redsack.
Whoa, whoa, I never said that.
Come on, man.
I didn't sleep because I was so excited to play Redsack.
That's what you said.
No, I said I didn't sleep because I had shit going on.
No, no, you were like, I love Redsack.
And you were like, yesterday I was playing Redsack.
Yeah, yeah, you're like, I was playing Redsack yesterday,
too.
And we're like, whoa, really?
Yeah, I was playing a bit.
I was playing a bit.
But that doesn't mean I'm good, you know.
But hey, at least my PC runs smoothly this time.
time you know that's one good thing yeah it always had me yo
yeah i'll tell you we nominated you as the group leader so
invite us yeah okay i'll give you one second i have i have
someone narrating the menus for me oh oh wait wait you
haven't even put up the game that means it's their first
time putting up the game i thought you said you played a
little bit i'll let you guys give me one second
is the best oh yeah we're talking about oh yeah apparently
axel axel wants to be a doctor so you could use a defib on
people or a pyromaniac or a pyro that's not a doctor that's
close enough close enough yeah one fucking one saves lives
the other you take lives i mean technically the doctor can
do both if you want to but nah nah it's designed to take
your life you know why it's they can keep they keep stealing
your money they you know they all have that cure you would
save people so you can make more money off of them you just
don't cure them fully so you cure them 90 no they'll like
keep coming back if you kill every time yeah yeah every time
i just fly back to osiland or fly over to japan i always
just pray i just hope that there is no cancer research
doctor on my plane you know what i'm saying i'm i'm always
like them i'm just like i pray the lord please no no
researchers on my plane why why not on your plane i mean
you're still here hey they don't get me if i talk too much
they all yeah they got them see the hose are watching like i
said watching bro all right party axel as a doctor join
party have you taken the Hippocratic oath or are you just a
hypocrite?
I don't think he's like, I don't think he's a servant.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, he definitely has not taken the Hippocratic oath.
I don't know what a hypocrite is.
He really is a doctor that can kill.
He is a doctor that can kill.
So a Hippocratic oath is something that every doctor takes
to make, that basically means you don't kill.
That's like the whole premise.
Nah, fuck that shit, dude.
Like, that's the oath.
You make an oath that you would never kill.
I am making an oath on something I can't promise, you know?
That's true.
What if I walk in the room and then they decide to blow
himself up?
You know, like, that's not really on me.
That's not your fault.
But it's gonna look like I did it.
Dude, I walk out of it.
How would it look like you did it?
Wait, you carry a bomb around you all the time as a doctor?
Yeah, you never know when the next Hector Salamanca is gonna
appear in a fucking room, you know?
Why would you carry a bomb around you?
Just carry a gun!
Is the house Hector Salamanca?
Well, I mean, it's easy.
A bomb can come in handy.
Ooh, talking about a bomb.
They, uh, they thought I, they thought I was a, they thought
I was a bomber.
What?
I went to the airport because my, my ASMR mic, it was in
like a case.
I thought you brought your ASMR, but we haven't done ASMR.
Wait, you've done.
Yeah, and, and, and, and I got like flick switches and shit
on it, right?
They thought I had like a bomb in there and shit.
I was like, ah, shit, sir.
And it was like an old gaza as well.
It was like handling that shit.
know what the fuck is tomorrow was it one of the breakdown
on everything yeah yeah is that one but he has that the
crazy expensive one yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't want to be
i'm not gonna be a jump leader also i hope there's no spmm
on this because like i don't remember i don't remember what
the hell is it yeah you know rspca whatever the hell that is
rspca what isn't that like the change chicken shit you know
what yeah I fuck with KFC you know me and KFC we go way back
okay I don't know I I think he's very tired I wait what
that's just how I feel spring marks you know he just kind of
I don't know what he's talking about anymore wait did they
change that what gun is why the hell is my god all right i
have what happens i have an assault rifle kit i have stun
grenades i'm gonna i'm testing my gun out oh that's me
testing my gun out it's a respawn pot tower gotcha sound guy
i lowered altair a little bit let me know if it's good okay
now i don't know why what's this oh i'm chilling i'm just
trying to fix my like sensitivity sniper rifle wait what do
you select mission for ducky you're pretty good at sniping
do you want don't even don't i don't even know what's gotten
is good here you're the sniper you've always been the
stripper you've always been the sniper oh hey knife
airstrike all right so now we're just looting looting oh my
god guys accidentally muted myself i forgot i had my push to
mute give me a second i i don't know you guys figure it out
yourself you guys are adults as well you know No, no, no,
actually, you're supposed to teach us!
If you don't teach us, we'll lower your KDA!
Oh, I don't give a shit about KDA, you know?
I'm not like one of those filthy KDA players.
Okay, then we'll bring you down with us.
What do you mean you are a filthy KDA player?
You just run away!
What is it?
You can call it...
I don't even know if my guns are...
Oh, you got a key card?
You can get attacked with that if you know that.
Yeah, I got a key card.
Wait, are we playing with bots?
I don't know.
How do I use my key card?
so you gotta go to that right you see you see you see what a
vehicle trailer or yeah yeah that one that one we gotta go
there yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah box yeah
yeah i hope we're against bots like i we need i we need help
we need up we need something can you find a defib in this in
this i think you gotta be a doctor to use the defib how to
be a doctor like other than 10 years of education uh you
become good friends with people in the government you know
oh they're sure true i can just like you know use political
power to become a doctor yes sir oh we could get a tank for
this oh i have a vehicle yeah that's great how do i do it
confirm the tanks are broken i don't know do i go over here
and just use my slide my card i think if you here all right
all right granted i just gotta wait it's a loot box axel to
loot box yay yes sir oh my god come on give me lamborghini
lamborghini come on gold gold gold i just want a tank gold
gold gold i don't even want a lamborghini bus i want a i
want a cyber truck it looks so ugly i just want good hot pot
man i hop on in it's a tank all right oh i got the cabin do
i get anything don't i'm chilling all right if you oh i'll
tear i'll tear you're literally the driver why did you get
out of the car i was i felt trapped in there with you
targeted wait what who's targeting us i don't know how do
people even okay we just gotta find people and kill them you
know yeah yeah can we let me know if you see anyone i think
so okay we're just chilling beep beep signal right oh so
there's a mission that someone picked where they try to kill
us oh someone picked a mission to destroy our tank hey what
would they do that we worked hard for this tank it's a
family tank oh wait is it that is that red shit over there
whoa whoa whoa whoa what is that no that's the ring oh shit
what the fuck i can't move i can't move over there oh my god
i'm leaving i'm leaving i'm leaving i'm leaving oh my god oh
artillery about entirely i don't think they're bots i don't
think they're bots they were absolutely not bots 17 purple
they're coming up coming up coming up yeah yeah
I sent one in as well.
Wait, what up?
I'm taking this guy down.
Wait, he was behind me this entire time?
Yeah, I was fucking him.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Okay, I need to get armor.
Give me a sec.
I'm...
Armoring, armoring, real quick.
He's running away.
Alright, alright.
I didn't even realize he was right behind us.
What does he have?
I have a grenade out.
I'm holding it.
Ooh, I want to upgrade.
Yoink.
Oh my god.
All right.
I think they're gone.
I think they ran.
Wait, they're getting killed.
They're getting killed.
Really?
They are?
How do you know?
No, that's my other side.
Oh, okay.
Let's push up.
Oh, wait.
I got a kill.
I killed Mr. Felice, you know.
Yeah.
These guys are definitely not bots though, for real.
Oh, wait, wait.
He's right here.
Right here.
Right behind that truck.
Oh, never mind.
No, no, no.
He's still there.
Oh, no.
alive you haven't killed him oh oh he's right there he's
right there oh my god i didn't see him oh god oh god he's
looking at me he's looking at me i got one i need a bet on
my way donkey please i need some help i need a bank it's
fine it's fine he doesn't need help he doesn't need help He
doesn't need help.
He's full HP.
You hope.
I got him.
I killed him.
Oh my goodness.
Okay, okay.
There's a guy in front of us.
Yes, yes.
He's right here.
Oh.
I don't really have cover.
I'm gonna back up a little.
Oh my god.
You can rest me behind this wall.
This wall is safe.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got sniped.
Stay with me.
Okay, okay.
I'm ready.
Appreciate it.
I think oh Oh my god, I got I got I got police deal again
There's an artillery I'm backing up, I'm backing up Oh, we
got squad weight, nice Oh, we got squad weight Yeah, we got
squad weight I'm grabbing armor One of my favorite ones over
the hedge Oh my god, how many Just keep running Okay, I'm
okay, I'm okay I'm okay Holy fuck we're so healthy Ngo's
your tank I my back was wide open I guess so healthy oh we
are not healthy we are not healthy that's a tank that's a
tank that's a tank oh what's the tank Oh look how many
minutes Oh I see the our how the hell did I okay I'm safe
I'm safe I'm safe dude why are they not destroying their
tank but when it's our tank everyone wants to get a piece of
it you know um guys they are right there that is hard to use
wow wait oh he's he's like no he saw me he saw me oh we got
redeployed nice here teeters the world gave pity on us oh
thank god second chance i was i was telling too much you
know they were like yeah that's not how come like when we
have a tank they all took a shot at us but when they have a
tank no one cared oh it's been looted has this been looted
get to that rv point move i'm checking oh someone just
landed what's that that's me that's not me that's not me i i
was lying oh wait that's a bike
a bicycle there is a right here enemy vehicle located i
don't know you saw me you might have saw me yeah you far as
fuck oh guys guys guys oh there is good luck and see you in
the next life yes okay remember no axel no remember me he
was so okay it's okay axel axel is alive oh okay never mind
what a hell are they what a um that's too difficult man
that's too difficult okay we're all split up okay how many
how many teams are there how many how many teams in total i
think there's like 70 70 80 90.
a couple yep um i just you know we were learning el tear and
i were learning so you know like i think we did pretty good
for people who never did the game yet you know i'm level two
yeah wait am i level 2?
yeah i'm level 2 too wait i see why do you always have to
steal my thunder wait no you're level one what do you mean
you're i'm level two no you're not I can see you can't
gaslight me like this no I won't let it happen I love I will
let it happen I can literally see that you love you're level
one on my screen like yeah I think you thought it was mine
mine's level oh hey i'm level two yay guys get a grind level
jesus you're only level 13 extra yes sir i got i got kicked
from the lobby what you did you're still party leader i'm
stupid never mind yeah i was gonna say it says you're party
leader why did it kick us from the squad uh from the quads
then i guess like the game felt bad for us was like you're
not ready apparently there's 25 squads so we did Yeah, we
did pretty well.
We're not last.
That's all that matters.
I just wish Axel would carry a little bit more.
Yeah, I know, right?
Yeah, I was looking at the score.
You know?
Look at that.
Altair got three kills.
I was harassing him.
Well, physically damage and mental damage.
Mental damage is sometimes more important to one another.
That's true.
You were doing the artillery strike.
Mm-hmm.
Exactly.
I have my ways of doing that.
Oh, wait, support.
Wait, defib.
I have defib.
We got a dude.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
And we have, oh my god, he's 1256.
He's gonna carry us.
He's on the controller.
He's a controller.
Andy as well.
That means he's just gonna...
He does.
He's a cheater.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We like that.
We like cheaters.
Mm-hmm.
But like, we don't endorse it.
Cheaters in this house.
But like, but like, that's a joke, guys.
We don't endorse hacking in video games.
only these raw skills wait i don't get a defense then what
the fuck it might be support for it meant uh moral support
oh that it's okay i'm moral support too oh wait we're
working for nato yeah we're working for nato we're here to
we're here for that was a nato you don't know terrorist
organization.
That's not what NATO stands for.
It is.
Notches and tacos.
Only.
Okay.
Here we go.
I'm breaking off.
I'm going solo.
Oh shit.
We got company.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait a minute.
Is there friendly fire in this game?
We got holes on us.
Uh, I don't.
There is?
Alright.
Is there or is there not?
Okay, no.
I was gonna test it out with someone.
There isn't.
Alright.
Who'd you shoot?
You shot me!
No, I didn't.
You don't have proof.
So you didn't take damage.
Wow.
I can't believe you was shooting me like that.
You have no proof.
You took no damage.
I saw it in the mud.
Alright, let's see.
Oh my god, that's not you!
Oh, that's not you!
Okay, yes, that's not you.
Oh, you see me?
I fell from the sky like Spider-Man!
Oh my god, my hero.
Okay, you got...
Where, where, where?
Okay, he's dead.
He's dead.
You baited me.
I thought it was you shooting me again, but this time I took
damage.
Also, there's a guy right here.
plan oh i see you oh where's the slide how do you slide in
this game double tap c double tap c yeah oh my god okay hero
assassin has a tank i don't know how oh on me on me on me
inside inside inside dumped him locked in yeah we got both
we got both that's right oh got your tag I got healer.
Alright.
Oh, they had good guns.
Yeah, they do.
Thank you.
Thank you for your guns.
Thank you for your kind donation.
I wonder where's the last guy?
That wasn't a squad right, though.
Homeboy died.
Oh, shit.
Assassin.
Wait, how did he die?
Oh, here!
I see him.
He's peeking through the...
Oh, that's how he died.
That's how he died.
He has a missile.
He's right here.
Oh, yeah.
Well, you know what?
That's when you go close range.
Yeah, I believe in you.
I'll watch from far here.
Oh, there he is.
He is over here.
He's over here.
Behind this.
Behind the...
Oh, my God.
Behind that.
Okay.
Got him.
Nice.
That's right.
Yeah, you just killed it.
Say hi to my grandma in the grave.
Damn.
Where the fuck is our guy?
Maybe inside?
Oh, he says the bazooka.
Yeah, he died, dad.
Don't worry.
He'll redeploy.
Mr. High Assassin.
Yeah, he's coming back.
He got kicked out of hell.
Whoa!
What?
Our welding just exploded behind us.
Oh, no.
Wait, someone's got to be in.
People, people, people, people.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, ping, ping, ping, ping.
Okay.
I've got a scout.
I'll take high ground.
I don't know where high ground is.
I'm going to...
There's somewhere on the left side, I think.
I don't think I can take high ground.
Toes on the left.
Alright.
Oh, no.
That's just Regis out there that I was just shooting.
One more, one more, one more.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I see him.
They parachuted.
So, they parachuted.
Granade!
I don't see anyone.
Can you guys ping?
Dude, Dad?
Ah, he's back.
Hmm.
We're somewhere over here.
Yeah, I saw like...
Oh, I see him.
I see him.
Fandom.
Ooh, this gun sucks.
He's right here.
He's right here on the roof.
He heard me.
I shot my gun.
He's still behind this.
He's just behind me.
this area.
Called Killed on?
Killed on?
Oh, he's not pushing up?
He's not peeking.
He's not peeking me.
I'm still behind here.
Wait, this is a different guy?
I thought- Parachute towards us.
What the heck?
That's a different guy we were fighting.
Yeah, I'm looking at I'm looking at a different guy from you
guys.
Oh, we all are looking at different dudes, shit.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, there's two teams.
He's shooting at a different team.
Well, it is what it is.
That's just That's what the war field is going to be like,
you know?
Are you okay over there?
Because I'm...
3,000 people out there.
I'm suppressing fire.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, you are not okay.
There's, like, a lot of people.
No!
Okay, I'm coming over.
I'm coming over.
I guess I'll help out now.
I swear, broke my legs.
I'm hit you.
I'm here.
Don't die.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait.
That's you.
oh i'm here somewhere on ping where red ping one okay red
ping okay there's someone up there as well i feel like i
don't see anybody watch out the silos there's like a lot of
people beside okay going up i'm getting armored i'm getting
60.
i don't see him he ping he's like here I don't he's not
peeking me now
He was up there On peace he's crashed I'll be shot from my
side who's shooting me from it.
Oh This guy right here.
That's it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh the shit.
Oh, no, we have redeploy so rush me like that.
I'll tear it now I have second chance.
All right, wait, can we like raise you or no after you full
die?
please Uh, now you gotta use the redeploy tower after that
Oh, guess what I see?
Guess what I see?
Oh, I see it.
Oh, I wonder what that is.
All right.
If it is two of us.
We just applied around a small little proximity, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it was quick, wasn't it?
Yeah, see, we did it.
All right, it's fine.
We can read a play to people.
That was a quickie.
Yeah, yeah, see?
We went and done.
Now Mr. High Assassin can come back in as well.
Yeah, we can actually carry us this way.
time yes sir i'm just out there going out getting kills and
then dying getting kills and then dying that's okay that's
what i do all right he should be fine now okay someone
actually did this area can you remember that i'm a medic and
i have i oh hey guys there is some heals here oh never mind
no more heals i accidentally used it you lied to me i
accidentally used them I'm used.
I feel stuck in here.
How do you get out?
Come on, grab this.
What?
I can't grab that gun.
All right.
Where the fuck?
I'm like trapped over here.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, was there anyone here?
I'm going to break through this glass that I'm going to loot
in.
Oh, shit.
That scared me.
Ouch.
Now chill, man.
There's shots west 300.
West 300?
All right, I'm heading over.
Oh, that is a...
Oh, do you need heals?
Oh, there is a lot of gunshots over there.
Oh, my God.
I think they're shooting at us, guys.
Yeah, I think so, too.
They might be shooting at us.
Let's just give them the axle and then we'll run.
All right, let's see.
I should need this gun.
Sacrifice.
Oh, I killed one.
Oh, what?
How?
Oh, I killed another.
Oh, no.
Wait, wait.
Where were you?
Actually, you got to talk.
You got to talk.
Oh, it's a truck.
It's a truck.
There's two holes in the truck.
On the left side.
There is a redeploy tower to my left, everyone.
Oh, I see.
I see it.
Getting shot from the cross.
Oh, we're there.
Over there.
There's just too many on us.
It's over on my left, on my left.
There's a guy next to that redeploy tower.
Yeah, I know.
I can't do anything about it.
I was trying to get there and then his team ran.
over there i think he's trying to read the floor too it's
okay take your time there's another there's another guy
right here bro i don't know what to do what i would do for a
chicken corn soup right now can you just go to a 7-eleven
they don't have chicken corn soup out of 7-eleven you know
the chinese style chicken corn oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i know
what i'm talking about yeah
Okay, they're just sending Are they selling?
They're sending it in.
Are you serious?
Bro, how am I a threat to you?
Oh, they're trying to redeploy.
You hear that?
Wendy, Wendy, the sirens?
They're trying to redeploy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where am I getting shot from?
I don't know, but I am inside right now.
Oh, nah, I got cheated, bro.
Wait, how did you, why are you all the way there?
There was a pew, pew.
Oh, I see them.
They're like all the way there.
can get redeployed you think it's possible all right i'm
going with your belief i can run through this open field and
not be punished surely surely i can streamer luck streamer
luck that's right i'm streaming this so i should be lucky
okay so like i don't know what the high assassin is doing
But how did he play this game?
How did he play this game to 53 levels and still play like
this?
Oh, hey, a loot box.
Oh, hey.
Mr. High Assassin only plays like an assassin.
He's just mad at him.
I know.
That means he's been doing this for, like, since Battle
Royale was released.
All he did is just hide.
I don't think he's ever won a game in his life.
All right, here we go.
Oh, he is, Mr. High Assassin.
He only plays at this time while high.
while being an assassin oh boy 1041 oh boy it'd be a shame
if oh boy oh boy let's hope oh nobody comes up oh wait wait
i didn't see oh my god he was crosswalking he was oh my god
he was He was actually rat bro.
He's oh my god.
He was baiting.
He was baiting for people for res's.
Oh my god I'm mr.
High assassin.
Don't worry.
I'm not interested in resing He's just looting It's like
yep, I'm just getting what I want.
Maybe let's give him benefit of the doubt You know, maybe
he's gonna go.
Okay, it's a party or squad.
Okay, yo, can you res us?
Wait, who the fuck why is the level five the jump leader?
Jesus this game always gives the lowest rank wait who am i
talking to i think that's all right before it starts oh okay
i think god i was like i was like who is travin travin nicks
and shoddy the logic what shoddy the logic yeah i have
shoddy the logic in my chat in my battlefield chat he's a
melody in my ear well he just got shot at oh there's someone
there he sees me bro what the is this guy Is he cheating?
Wait, is he cheating?
Wait, there's no way he's walling.
Wait, what?
Why did he just...
He's on a controller as well.
Wait, what?
Is he...
Oh my god!
Wait!
Wait, he sees him.
He sees him.
Wait, I think...
Wait, wait a minute.
Guys, is he walling?
Guys, do you think he's...
Maybe, maybe he has...
Guys, do you think he's walling?
You did Clara and stuff.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, no, he's cheating.
He ain't cheating.
No, yeah.
He was shooting the wall though.
Okay.
Maybe he's just...
Why was he looking at that wall and tracking someone?
I don't know.
It's kind of sus.
It's kind of...
We did better that time.
13 players.
Yeah, 13 players.
Let's go.
13.
Not bad.
I only got two kills.
Ooh, I was smoking them, dude.
Yeah, I won.
Five kills.
Okay, but you did kill steal.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
no no you skills yeah no no two of those kills were mine two
of those kills were mine i was almost sick ah okay god damn
yeah axel why do you keep stealing my kills too man come on
obviously you stole all tears kill you want to steal from
the noobs from the noobs that's crazy yeah what is this i'm
not like a level i'm not like out of fucking supermarket at
10 a.m all the moms after dropping off their kids at primary
school they go to the supermarket grabbing the last fucking
set of the fucking you know dumpling pack being like hey hey
hey i had my hands on that first exactly exactly i then they
go home and get locked in on battlefield six jesus i don't
know that guy feels six it's just battlefield supermarket is
just like a battlefield for moms i guess hey a battlefield
for moms it's a battle it's the battle royale for good shit
and the cheap shit quick you know distribute health packs to
teammates when they directly interact with you i like how do
you guys directly interact with me okay oh okay guys if you
press e on me you'll get health packs wait uh don't keep her
you're only level two no nah, oh I'm level three.
I'm level three.
You're level two on my own.
Na-na, na-na, na-na.
And Axel's level 14.
Axel's always watching.
The Hose are watching.
What are they doing?
Why are they watching, Axel?
Are they jealous?
I don't know.
Yeah, why are they watching?
Why are they watching, guys?
Don't they know, bros before hose?
Yeah.
want to be a hope get a bro that's how oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh wait i can customize my gun i forgot about that i don't
remember like what's just a good gun though aren't you guys
excited for winter time though isn't it like christmas music
and and holiday and cheer and no you know what sucks about
winter it's cold i love the cold no you don't the cold is
better than the hot honestly I prefer the hot over the cold
Christmas not good you don't get red pocket, you know
Christmas not good.
That's true.
That's true No red pocket not worth it.
Yeah, unless they give you money for Christmas I mean shit
if I get money for Christmas then I'll love Christmas man
shit I just ask for money the older you get what the hell?
Yeah Who you been asking for money shit just be like I won't
be like I want to buy my own presence so just give me money
I will still take a steam gift card oh that's true I'll take
a steam gift card too oh I'm with I'm Hades a PC I believe
in him he's level 30 yeah and he likes Hades you know that's
like a bad shit that's like a bad you right yeah he's a yeah
he's a oh shit guys guys I guess I oh my i almost i cut my
parachute and i thought i was gonna fall oh yeah it's fine
if you fall you fall you know yeah that's just life you know
truly inspirational axel if you fall you fall you fall what
can you do to stop it you're already falling anyway exactly
you just got accepted just enjoy the free fall just like
your csgo investments you know i'm saying yeah i remember
you guys yes yes you ever went you guys kept trying to
convince me to invest in cs yes I'm old, everything's done.
I'm out.
I'm out too.
Guys, I don't think you guys should keep opening for knives,
guys.
You would have made so much money.
I was like, you might have known, guys.
You would have made so much money, Madrella.
You should have done it.
For those who don't know, these two try to get me to buy
cases.
I don't know.
Yeah, yeah, what height?
It's better.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, so what's your portfolio like now?
After I think I made like 3 or 4k off of just knives.
I'm not even kidding.
Wait, really?
You sold early before the Yeah, yeah, of course Okay, but
what's your overall profit?
Or what profit?
Yeah, overall profit.
Overall profit you I think you've lost I think you lost
money I'm always good at that shit, you know, how the heck
did I open that?
artillery strike ish strike.
What?
Oh, I got an artillery strike.
Oh, that's good.
That's always good.
There's an artillery strike here as well.
What's this gun?
Okay.
I don't know what gun is.
Good.
At chat, what's a good gun?
Chat's like my chat GPD.
Good chat GPD.
Yeah.
I don't even know if I have a good gun or not.
Oh, I would like a frag grenade, though.
Oh, that's not what I wanted.
Give me that frag grenade.
where's my oh it's g okay all right wait what's six where
should we go we're all in the corner of the map so we should
probably go somewhere yeah we should head somewhere but i'm
gonna head over to axel i'm just looting man what's it mark
this artillery deployed smoke oh i can deploy smoke screen
oh yeah that is a pretty strong hey yeah yeah we can like go
something we can like cross open areas so I haven't we gonna
do the missions don't we I have an upgrade kit kit for an MK
ever MG whatever that is machine gun okay I have a machine
gun upgrade kit if anyone wants it because I don't I can't
upgrade mine for some reason I don't think I can use yeah I
can't use it oh wait wait wait wait look at that chopper
What was it?
Wait, can I want to fly a chopper?
A chopper.
Our chopper is a shit.
But wait, where's our gal?
Hades is still looting.
Hades.
Come on, Hades.
Come with us.
Come on, guys.
Hades.
Watch this, guys.
Watch this.
Area marked.
There's people in it.
In front of me.
Okay, okay.
Oh, no, no, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I have something that's coming in very soon.
Oh, my God.
Reloading.
I'm reloading.
Okay, it's fine.
Don't worry.
I have don't worry.
I deployed the smoke.
This is why I needed it.
I killed one.
Okay.
On my way.
Nice, nice, nice.
I have someone on me.
I killed another.
Kill another.
Nice, nice.
Nice.
Oh, I think we pulled down.
Pull down.
I didn't even see anyone.
It's fine.
Oh my god, that smoke actually worked.
Oh, I got shot at it.
Used it for myself.
That's crazy.
Oh, I got an intel case.
I got XP for us.
I did that.
I used the smoke for a joke, and it actually worked out for
me.
Oh, hey.
Oh, what is this?
Oh, is this a sniper rifle?
Oh, there's an airstrike.
Because I don't want the airstrike.
I got an airstrike.
I'll take it then.
What?
We just do four airstrikes on that.
Oh, my gosh.
You know what?
Let's do it.
Boom.
I'm repeating you four booms.
today yeah boom headshot boom headshot still getting kills
like oh i see him i see him i see him that's nice nice shot
don't worry i put an airstrike right there wait no no i'm
running up no no no no no no oh he's dead dad i know shit
he's dead we killed him How did you get up there?
There's a ladder.
Wait.
Air strike next to us.
Oh, there is an air strike next.
What if you just send a couple more?
Yeah, do it.
All right.
Bet, bet, bet, bet, bet.
Do it, do it, do it, do it.
Don't be pussy.
I'm looking through the thermal thingy.
I'm seeing people.
Yeah, where are these people?
I'm sending it in.
I can't see anybody.
I don't see anyone out there.
Where is this guy's team?
team too because it wasn't a full down oh what is going on
holy shit guys i don't i don't know they're still there
anymore you see anybody under your third floor left side oh
yeah i see my same as him 16.
50 yeah that's 20 something fuck he's over here he's over
here
see him anymore it's not oh i see i see him 42 feels
dangerous 17 he has the teammates here left he has a
teammate over there one just one just uh parachuted yeah
yeah yeah i destroyed their drone they were sending you in a
bomber they just gotta got out is that your recon whose
recon is that there's down there they're down there as well
i think they just drove away is there's a couple of people
surrounding us right now oh i don't like that that's not
cool Let's not go up.
Banana, no, no, no, no, no.
Banana, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We like animals, animals, animals.
Copyright, copyright.
How the hell is that?
I'm not breaking.
Bro, I don't...
Do we move?
Do we leave?
Oh, whoa, whoa, I missed you.
I'm getting here.
He's right here.
We shot right side back of that building.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
North 30.
also here 1735 fresh i shot they're all like on the other
you know i'm standing i'm standing an airstrike i'm saying
you're straight send the donkey send it in there you go it's
gone in the choppa calling the choppa go in destroy their
home destroy their home and their and their bloodline and oh
oh my goodness
blew into that glass.
That's it?
Well, that was nothing.
That airstrike fucking sucked.
That was like one shot.
You can.
We gotta get into zone.
Are we not in zone?
Oh, we are not in zone.
Yeah.
We ain't in zone.
Okay, so there might be a team over here, so you gotta be
careful.
They're right below us.
Right below us.
Okay.
I am right above them.
Oh, wait, wait.
It's right here!
Oh, shit!
Oh my god.
That was not a teammate.
That was not with me.
Why me?
There's a long range weapon here if anyone wants to.
I just looked at him.
Yeah, I was like, I was wondering why you were looking at
him.
Did he have armor?
No, he doesn't.
Oh yeah, I saw rifle.
I'll upgrade that.
Oh, there's a sniper rifle too.
Oh, squad white.
Nice.
Does there have extra armor?
I can give you some armor.
I got a few.
Yeah, I have one.
How do I drop it?
How do I drop this?
Oh, you're right.
All right.
Drop some armor here.
What the heck is that?
The Fortnite built everything.
I am...
Yeah, see that?
I'm armoring up.
What the hell is that?
What are you guys looking at?
I just saw it fought.
East 30.
Jesus Christ.
All right.
No more second chance, ladies.
Oh, all right.
We don't need second chance.
We're gamers.
Not ammo.
Oh, okay.
That's not good.
Never mind.
Where are you guys?
Where are they shooting?
Where are you shooting at?
East 30 up the hill.
There's a floating platform.
Oh, my God.
Wait, they aren't?
Wait, he hits that?
Yeah, he's kind of crazy.
I don't even know.
He's crazy with that.
I don't even know, like, my drop off for this.
Wait, they are actually hitting.
As I'm saying, I don't even know the drop off for this.
Holy shit, they said, they really said, let me hit.
And I was like, yeah, okay.
Okay, I need to be high.
He has to be high.
There's a car below us.
Okay, we gotta go to the zone.
Guys, guys, guys, we gotta go to the zone.
I'm leaving.
Okay, I'm heading over there.
Oh, I'm serpentine.
Yeah, I'm moving into zone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm moving too.
I'm moving as well with you.
I'm right behind you.
They're still trying, the fortnighters are still trying to
shoot at us.
It's okay.
Let them fortnight, you know?
Alright, I see gunshots to our left.
I hear gunshots to our left.
But how far?
Oh, we are so far from zone.
Wee!
You can cut these people off at chemical storage ahead of
us.
Wait, where the fuck are you going?
We gotta go in a zone.
It's the blue ship, right?
We gotta go.
Yeah, I was just shooting at the guys on the left.
Oh, okay.
Cause I was just saying.
People on the left.
Yeah, yeah.
People behind us.
Behind us?
Oh, I'm looking.
Oh, he's behind that box.
Oh, you are so close to the zone, the zone, the zone,
though.
Let's see.
Running, running.
I'm running.
I'm with...
I'm with Altair right now.
That people...
Uh, West 330.
West 330.
They're running away.
I'm going right.
Who the fuck is that an artillery drop?
Yeah.
I might be the first one that gets shot at, and I also have
the least HP.
So, good luck to me.
I don't know how to drop any to you.
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
I just got cocky and stood in front of a sniper.
I have high ground though.
I got high ground.
I've got the high ground now, donkey bird.
I don't have high ground very soon.
I don't have high ground anymore.
I'm so scared.
I don't see anyone beside me.
Wait, Hades is so far away.
Absentee teammate.
Yeah, he's so far.
Let's see.
Hey, welcome back.
Oh, God, you're so fast.
What the fuck?
Oh, you can cut.
You can just cut.
Wait, I hear I hear I hear a car.
I hear a car in front of us.
Yep.
Wait, how do I get through?
oh it's over here let's see i do have a sniper i found where
those people were shooting us from yeah it's like an airport
tower they're still shooting people from down there are they
still doing it
try to figure out a is there a zoom on the sniper how the
guys zoom in uh zayman and scroll up and down maybe like
classic classic pub j style wait what app what and then zoom
in what then scroll wait i see someone oh wait wait i see
hose i see hose i see i can't i shoot can't shoot i shot 20
20 20 20 20 nice nice nice yeah yeah yeah mr radies let's go
i got shot i got shot i got shot i don't know where i don't
know where i don't know where i don't know where i don't
know where i have to go i have to go i have to go oh i'm
about i'm I'm blocked.
Yeah, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'll try to cover.
I'm trying to cover, but they might push me.
We gotta get inside.
I couldn't.
I was trying to cover.
Oh.
No, no, no.
Oh, Hades, you're wild.
You're wild.
There's a guy literally in front of us.
You're fucking crazy.
I'm covering.
I'm heading over.
Oh, look at we go inside.
There's two teams two teams two teams two teams get inside
get the wall I'm going over I'm going over It's really
crazy.
Oh my god Hades Hades my man Yeah, I was firing those he's a
hero sticking it.
I was sticking in those guys ass too.
You should see Are you still there?
Are you still behind us?
Yeah, yeah, they're still sitting right here They're coming
there they're coming there That guy crouching there.
Oh, shit I got it.
A strike.
We gotta run.
I'm going over.
Ooh.
Running out of AR ammo.
There's a house in there.
House in here.
Hey, I'm heading over here.
Think we're safe.
For now.
Looking for AR ammo.
ADW kit.
I haven't seen any ammo, unfortunately.
Oh, I should...
I just see guns.
No ammo.
Yeah.
Intel.
I hear footsteps.
I don't know if that's us.
Chat say nothing.
I don't know if that's us still.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
People in there.
Why is this a step?
21, 21.
Right here.
On my way.
Oh, I got shot.
This gun fucking sucks.
I found out.
I'm right behind.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's not fine.
I'm like right here behind the chopper.
On my way.
Behind the chopper.
I'll get to the chopper.
All right.
Oh, I got out the gun.
Oh, my bag has ammo.
I didn't know that.
Okay, guys, I'm going to put up my bag out, and you guys can
grab ammo from this.
All right, baby, baby, baby.
I have no armor as well now.
Yeah.
I have another car.
Another car.
Oh, not here.
I see him.
Oh, the ice is not over here.
They're over here.
I don't have ammo.
I have ammo.
Axel.
All right, baby, baby.
Cheers, cheers.
This is a pretty cool fighting spot.
bro are you okay i got him i got him i got him i got him i
got him i got him i got him who the hell shot me from right
here right here right here i got one of them but oh thank
you i can throw another oh hang in there that's it yeah i
can throw it cancels me it canceled me i'm sorry look at me
stay with me all right fine goodbye i died though oh no it's
hated i'll say it it's up to you oh no nice oh shit you got
the squad wire I believe see I told you I believe it's okay
you in Hades it's you in Hades oh no oh god I believe I
believe in the Hades it's okay it's okay okay mr.
Hades seems to know what is yeah he knows that he's a hero
he's a hero oh no Hades is good Hades is good no was kind of
nasty yeah yeah his that flick was good that's his like was
insane it's the controller it's the controller and the
special all right what i learned is whatever guys whatever
gun i had that gun was garbage that recoil was fucking one
down Hades had armor Hades is pushing Hades is pushing Hades
pushing he's pushing he's heading over he's pushing oh my
god the controller and the special oh wait you're laying
down and shit too oh my god oh shit one more one more one
more ah behind me no that was close how did I get my behind
me that sixth place i thought that was like the last two
teams i felt like the last two teams we were kind of yeah we
were yeah it was pretty good all right good job on the 12
looted chests we're learning yes sir i'm the new problem
chat what gun did i have because that gun was garbage i'm
not picking that gun up again i had like some gun that was
only for close range and the recoil was so bad now hades was
definitely mvp though now hades was kind of good yeah he was
good oh yeah yeah actually i was expecting him his name yeah
he was he lived up bro let's invite him let's go yo hades
hades come on hades and join us come on hades i'm gonna add
hades Who the fuck is this, bitch?
Like, squad management.
Bug, not start.
Bug.
Oh, what?
I'm going to...
Wait.
Social.
How do I add you?
I can't even add him.
Wait.
Oh, party leader start.
Add me.
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait a bit.
Cancel.
Do I cancel Q?
I don't know.
How do I add?
How do any of us add?
Don't want me to go back to the lobby or?
Yeah, yeah.
Go back to.
Yeah.
What fucking Riz did you use on Hayes?
Bro, I just said join us.
That's it.
Hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, he's a fan.
All right.
How do we get you in?
Woo-hoo.
Friend request.
Oh, wait.
You're like, hey, these, my hubby.
Join the squad, you know?
Yeah, hey, hey, hey, hey.
I recently met.
Where is he?
Wait, that would kind of go hard.
Hades, Hades, kebab.
I would go to that for like if he was ever running one.
Hades, ramen.
Do we have?
I don't even see Hades.
Hades, add me.
I have high assassin.
Okay, wait.
I'm Hades PC, right?
Was that his name?
I'm Hades PC.
I got it.
Yeah, I'm Hades PC.
Yeah, okay.
I sent him a request come on kid mom please get in there get
in there all right all right I added him where is he I got
him in he's gonna carry us all right come on cut your kick
he's 80s your kick yeah I got him in the party clutter kick
buddy yeah I gotta give him the gotta give him you know a
bit of energy boost hey if you win this round you get to the
knife you get clutch or kick i will unbox another knife if
you win this round if you win this round i will give you the
knife if we are not top 10 we kick the best i could do is
you know maybe eat a kebab here and we're taught if we're if
we place 11 you're out we're getting a new person in That's
true.
We look for a new puppy.
Yeah, we're looking for, we're scouting for a new, we're
gonna put you back in the shelter and adopt a new kid.
No!
Go back to the orphan as you go.
It just wasn't a match.
I think I'd be open for adoption.
Not me being adopting, but me adopting someone.
Maybe in the future.
How much can you make from that?
What do you mean, adopting?
That's what's not about profit, man.
Yeah, it's called, it's like, you know, they say like couch
whipping, right?
Well, oh, you mean like welfare.
Like, the more kids you adopt, the more the money the
government gives you.
No, no, no.
It's like couch whipping, right?
So you invest in the kids, right?
That you adopt.
So then they go to a good university, like Harvard and shit,
let's say.
And then they take good care of you, right?
It's an investment.
Yeah, yeah.
That's all children.
Or you just start Project LeBron James, and you know, like,
dingles out for Harambee.
yeah just be like come on come on lebron let me adopt your
child please and then he'll be like all right project lebron
let's go you adopt one you adopt lebron and just be like
show me your tallest kid it's out here you're going to
orphanage like i want your tallest child please and then you
go like from orphanage and orphanage and compare the orphan
height to be like this would this would be the child an
orphan battle royale see which kid is standing in last when
you think about it isn't that what people do about pets and
dogs and stuff like that yeah that's how you do like the dog
shows finish of the whatever the they call it you know so it
was like that has to be illegal no just be like oh i just
want to have a child who i can play basketball with and then
like you know you that you like hey can you like do i shoot
some poops
Isn't Blue Rock like that?
I thought like that, that Blue Rock, that fucking soccer
anime is about like death game survival, but like they made
it with soccer, right?
I thought it was just normal.
Wait, I've never watched it.
I think so.
They just get exiled from the National Academy.
I just heard that like, I just know like it's like it's like
it makes soccer hard.
I wish I could just exile anyone from the Academy too, man.
My fucking Umamu Sumer runs when they fuck me over.
and just put them in the glue factory expel these expel
these horses you know like spell the horses you should make
him into some delicious oh yeah it's good it's good really
good yeah i'm going here the beef beef uk as well jesus oh i
love uk like the raw yeah uk with the egg yolk in the in the
Oh, yeah.
Oh, that's just good.
It's really good.
I have...
This building sucks.
I think I hear people above.
Oh my god, what?
Okay.
Yeah, no, you don't do that.
Goodbye, ladies and gentlemen.
I am going on an adventure.
Nice.
I lived.
I don't know how to fuck that guy lost the fight.
He said...
have a look and knock out what is this oh my god wait i got
deep fit i got deep fit uh-oh that means we're not making it
to top 10 guys no no no no i got deep guys no no we're fine
we'll be fine get a squad kill with that don't worry you got
this i got deep i'm running i'm i'm running out with my deep
fit right now what gun do i have anyway lmg oh anti-air
vehicle drop the villars oh wait i want that but i hear
people okay hostile i gotta get over to you guys wait it
doesn't oh my god okay defense doesn't guys i found out that
defib doesn't work on enemies okay i'm okay i'm okay i'm
okay wow i'm in you um there is like a lot of people on me
guys well on my way i'm good luck good luck to you i'm
looting i'm a loot goblin i just i don't know i don't know
because i had come on guys we're we're on our own you know
we're our own man you're on our own i don't even know what
gun i used to kill these people Matsu!
Oh shit!
Oh!
I fell down!
It's okay, it's okay, there's a whole entire team.
Entire team?
There's two teams.
I'm at the very bottom.
There's one on me.
You're so healthy.
Yo, yo, we're getting like, scream sniper.
I'm at the bottom.
I'm at the very bottom.
Okay.
Three people on me?
It's okay.
see it we're so good we're so safe i don't mind being down
because during this time i'm down i can browse twitter you
know what i'm saying all i'm saying except if you were with
us you would not have got down no no no i was trying i was
getting ready to res you at the the deploy you'd be chilling
with me yeah and dokey's blood stain on the ground exactly
i'm chilling on twitter you know you're doom scrolling no no
you're looking at the cosplayers aren't you wait dookie that
let me open this up oh yeah you're an engineer oh i'm
covering you i'm covering you you know you're back alive
you're alive right now oh one mixed kebab please i'm gonna
grab that axel what would your death like what would be what
would be your last meal yeah my last meal do i get the older
as much as i want or is it just one meal no yeah like a
reasonable meal reasonable meal okay shit uh god honestly
anything would be good like a bowl of noodle sounds good
like you know nothing too crazy uh you know yum cha that is
good too you get a bit of everything a little bit of this
yeah a little bit of this a little bit of that you know you
get so you just want everything huh yeah i do i want some
sushi maybe all right we're picking one meal than one last
what's one there's people on me there's people on me oh if
it's a one last dish dokey we gotta we gotta we gotta get
back with the squad no no no they gotta get back to us what
the dish is if it's made by my mom it could be any dish
really on my last meal i think i'm one like like there's
like people over there handmade it's like right over there
behind this stack of dirt
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, artillery.
Artillery, artillery.
We gotta go.
It's fine.
I'm okay up here.
Why the fuck does he have artillery?
He just spawned in.
Hey, so Hades with us, Axel.
You're on your own, buddy.
Yeah, no, I'm just looking at him.
I'm like, hello.
May I please get a kebab?
Don't see him.
Wait, I have an anti- what is this?
I have an anti-vehicle drop.
What does this do?
It's an anti-vehicle drop.
It stops vehicles from dropping.
Oh, what?
That doesn't mean.
Oh my God, we gotta make so much sense.
Wait, behind what I know.
Wait, that's a chopper!
Drone!
Come back over here!
Oh, that's Hades.
Oh, fucking chopper.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
There's a chopper.
I bet.
All right.
Are you guys ready?
Yes, sir.
I'm on a I'm on a gap Alright, here we go I don't even know
where they are Here we go Here we go Helicopter What does
that mean?
Wait, what does that mean?
Wait, wait, wait, wait What does countermeasure do?
Okay, it's fine, it's fine It's fine, we're so healthy We're
so healthy Oh, we're so healthy Wait, how did you die?
How did you die?
No, no, you don't know that.
You don't know that.
Donkey!
He's constantly killing me, right?
He's constantly killing me.
You guys did amazing out there.
I'm proud of you.
See, this is why the chopper is bad.
I don't understand.
Gamers don't look up.
Why do these gamers look up?
How did they know?
It's going like...
Okay, none of us looked up when the chopper was above us.
that's not true maybe we're not gamers that is all that is
so that is not true redeploy that's where the attack is here
I have I have second chance Axel does it but I do I'm just
chilling bro gotta get you where are you gonna browse
Twitter oh wait there you guys okay oh yeah what are you
browsing who are you browsing huh the timeline bro timeline
timeline which cosplay yeah give us the ads yeah bro i don't
just i don't just draw for free you know we gotta buy the
package if you want if you want to know the buy the package
oh yeah sorry oh the tier five subs no yeah like the gifted
memberships the recommended uh best top tier cosplayers join
my course it's in the description starts at five yeah if you
join his membership the best list he has the list of like
the best cost layers of course it's a course i have taught
so many student one student the other month has made 30k
from looking at this course yes sir make sure to join my
course because it is totally legit not a scam i'm floating
in the skies man i should oh squad why did you get him you I
killed someone.
Oh Yeah, you killed the one guy.
Nice There's a lot of guns here by the way Axel where I'm at
Yeah, I'm trying to fly in Yeah, we're at the Boston
Dynamics Right now, you know like the RoboDogs I don't know
Matt What?
You okay?
I died What?
Yeah, nice It's the gas powdered potato That fucking killed
me again?
Wait, where is he?
I don't know man.
They just they just really seem to know where I am every
time guys Yeah, that's fuck.
Yeah, it's kind of fuck man.
I think it's cuz they heard wait Look
Oh, nice
Don't tell me there's another guy There is another guy.
No, no.
I said don't tell me there's a Yeah, there you go there you
go, there you go there you go.
Nice nice nice nice nice bit guys i said don't tell me i
need to get more i got my guy my guy my guy my guy wow you
guys are just cleaning them up that's right all right i'm
also gonna throw this here see look at that we did it got an
airstrike i'm gonna grab that nice oh i'm gonna oh there's
more arm armor here by the way That's his own.
That's his own.
I'm going in.
Bro, Hades was mad.
You fucking started yelling.
Wait, guys, how do we get out of here, guys?
Where's the door?
Whoa, what's he yelling?
What's he yelling?
Oh, it's over here.
Oh, that's a big-ass fire.
No, I don't know.
I didn't even know what Ling...
I don't even know what Ling, say i don't know if that was
english oh he was like i mean he was passionate can we take
this ambulance oh every fbs game guys you're muted by the
way sorry mr crimson ruse the famous crimson ruse is rated
me so i just had to say oh yeah during the war well is
someone called me on my cell phone so oh my god you'll pick
up a cell phone while you're getting shot at in the war
would honestly i'd answer cell phone for you anymore really
that's kind of game that's true that i mean to be fair
you're like oh it's you know you're like um the last time
you'll ever hear oh wait there's like a guy oh someone shot
me someone shot me i don't know who someone shot me on my
way on my way on my way i don't know who i'm just bro i
don't know who i don't know who's shooting me they know
where you are they hear me they have all the almost clean
guys there's I don't know where.
I'm a little scared.
Let's get over here.
Or a little bit closer.
I want to see if I can get to the...
Oh my god, I actually pressed chat.
I'm probably stood still for one second.
Look at him know you're a VTuber.
Look at him quit.
Hades is going to leave us.
Bro, Hades was in my chat.
He's not going to leave us.
He's right or die.
What if he doesn't know?
I'll ban him from my chat if he leaves.
that's right big team over there on top north 30 artillery
strike assault rifle i just wanted to see if there's
anything good here i'm gonna try to get to these oil wells
over here try to get some shelter because you know oh
there's like a team right in front of the oil rings gotcha i
wish i could find someone who always owns like a like a oil
rig or whatever like a Yeah, dude, shit.
There's a guy right here.
There's a team right behind you.
Okay.
I can try and do the redeploy if you, like, cover.
Sure, I'll watch him.
Yeah, yeah, cover me.
I'm gonna go straight for the redeploy.
Thank you very much.
Oh, there's a team right in front of us, too.
Oh, shit, what happened to cover me?
What happened?
Oh, my.
North 30, North 60.
That was not covered me.
I could only cover one board of you.
I'm sorry.
That was not covered.
Oh, no.
There was a side team.
There's three teams here.
No, there's three people here.
I don't think I got covered, guys.
I don't.
Dang.
There's a guy on the top of the hill, by the way.
Whoa.
Jade died.
You're still the guy on the top.
Oh.
My snipe.
13.
You know what?
That's a 13.
Not top 10, though.
Wait.
Hades.
Convince us not to kick you.
Why should we keep you for another game?
Because I'm cool.
Fight for your spot, Hades.
Who left the lobby?
Wait, did he leave the lobby?
There's no way.
No, he said bad.
No, he's bad already.
I can't believe it.
He's not trying to convince us.
He left our party.
Wait, he left?
Uh-oh.
You guys made him nod.
No, it wasn't me.
It wasn't me.
I think it's because someone didn't cover us.
I was covering you.
I was watching these people very gently.
He left because someone else didn't cover us.
wasn't me.
Axel, why didn't you cover her?
Yeah, Axel, why didn't you cover us?
I was dead.
Come on, Axel.
Yeah, but like you could have not been dead.
Nah, fuck that.
I'mma be dead, yo.
You could have been alive.
This rat is falling for me.
You know, all in all, Hades was pretty cool.
Yeah, he was pretty.
He was pretty.
He was pretty pretty, all right.
He was cool.
Better than Axel.
Whoa, well, I ain't no better.
yeah I'm just I got I got five kills there that's all I'm
saying I got five kills I got three damage how much damage
did you have access me yeah I don't know oh you know what
you could do is you could check your your squad no fuck that
you know people are all hiding something nah nah not
something somebody's hiding anything don't scare you don't
want to they want to show it who's our who's our new fourth
i'm still support oh wait we don't have a fourth player
might not have a forest we don't have guys guys why did you
bully haiti's away alter why did i said nothing i actually
forgot that he was gonna leave i forgot i can't forget next
time okay yeah you gotta be nicer man yeah i'm sorry hades
yeah better than okay you were really good that's good good
on you for apologizing even though it was your fault i'm
glad you i'm sorry that donkey was too heavy for you okay
all right someone had five kills that game and it was me
okay you guys got a new guy pantera Pantera.
Pantera.
I believe in him.
I bet he'll be better than Hades.
Makes me want to eat garlic shrimp.
Pantera?
Why?
Yeah.
No idea, man.
But I'm just hungry.
Would you like...
How...
Are you good at...
Wait.
Are you good at this game?
Pantera.
if a homie got you had okay you had to say that because Axel
still wouldn't do it he'd let that guy die we're open to
replacements we're open to you know we're opening auditions
opening auditions for the newest English wave of this is the
replace Axel series they will be my test subjects.
What will happen to a human if you put them in, you know,
like in a pressure cooker?
Why a pressure cooker?
Ooh, I wonder what would happen.
I feel like someone has done it before.
Well, it depends on what would happen to this poor little
man if I put in a microwave.
I mean, radiation.
I'll just be the next Mr. Beast.
What would happen if I put someone in a microwave?
You know, he made his own Mr. Park in Dubai.
Yeah, he made Mr. Beastland.
I bet we could do that.
Yeah, we can make...
I'll be like, yeah, Naruto and Sakai.
Mr. Beast, he's like a counterpart.
There's Mr. Beast and then there's Mr. Beastiality.
Whoa, okay, that's a very different thing.
So I don't...
I don't know, yeah.
That's a very, very different thing.
It's not too different.
So what do you do, what do you do on that land?
Can you please explain?
You put people in microwaves.
So, so, so.
How are you a businessman, Axel?
So why would these people come to your land?
I want to go to Axel's land because I want to die.
It's the next thing.
It's not even like humane either, you know?
It's not even like a humane way to die.
Well, that's for them to decide if it's humane or not, you
know?
I think that's up to, I think that's up to like, I don't
know, the UN to decide what's the UN what do you mean what's
the UN United Nations universal oh universal yeah yeah
universal would decide if it's universal studios will decide
all right anyone else line with us I don't think so Okay, we
came to broke broke island.
Oh, is this broke island?
What makes it broke island?
It's a broke island.
I got some good shit.
I got some okay stuff.
Yeah, I got armor I got a whole two stacks of armor Intel
case I need to use more of my like like util.
I don't use my stuff my my grenades enough What's this
vehicle supply No.
Sensor EV mine.
No idea what that does.
There's apparently a tank here, but anyone finds a card.
There's a card.
There's a tank here.
Thank you very much on the way.
Thank you.
I don't know if we should take the tank because we just got
targeted and died.
I mean, if we have a card, I think it's fine.
There's no way there's missile people that's early in the
game.
there's no way i'm going up this mountain
i'll have to bring out tear down a little bit yeah i got you
all right i brought him down you're drowning me out no
that's what you get for bullying haiti's i gotta speak my
truth what truth all you do is serious is smarter than it
looks wait really do i make people cry oh i want to bomb
this place i'll make people cry Which place?
Yeah, I'm going to bomb their house.
You're a bomb, y'all.
Do it.
No boss.
That'll be fun too, you know.
Do it.
Everyone is tied to, like, one straight.
West.
And one of them has a bomb strapped to them.
I'm, like, stuck here.
I don't know how to get through this.
Cut the fence.
Can I cut the fence?
Oh, my God.
I can cut the fence.
Okay.
All right.
I figured it out.
I did not realize that.
She figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
No assistance whatsoever.
With a pencil and a pen, she figured it out.
Wait, where did you say people were out there?
West, southwest, about pretty far.
I'm like looking.
I'm right here.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, no, that's just...
Whatever it's like here.
I don't see any...
Whoa!
Wait, is that missile?
don't see anybody I don't see Axel where's Axel?
Oh I'm looting they call me a loot gobbler I don't see
anyone here wait Pantara's so far Pantara's gone gone it's a
pretty good skin Pantara Onka right Axel?
Pantara what?
Pantara Onka it's a CS skin I think yeah hey which one is
that one I actually don't know it's the one with the panther
on it yeah that's why it's called pan there the only panther
i know is panther links it's it's a pokey's machine have you
guys seen what machine it's a pokey yeah it's a machine
called panther link pokey's yeah see when you say pokey's
everybody thinks you're saying poker no no no no no it's the
pokey's machine my my friend's favorite machine He keeps
telling me to play it, but I'm like, nah, nah, nah.
I don't really like- Can you say mayonnaise?
Mayonnaise.
Also, there's a drop right here.
Okay, on away.
All right.
Let's start and end the war for once and all.
End the war?
Catch up our mayonnaise.
Wait, it depends.
It depends.
Is it QP?
Is it QP mayonnaise or regular mayonnaise?
Oh, yeah, you get the pick and choose.
You get the pick.
I get the pick.
I'm a ketchup person.
What's wrong with you?
I like my eggs with ketchup.
You know what QP mayonnaise?
It's delicious, try it out.
It's just saltine oil.
I never had QP mayonnaise.
Oh, that's why you never have QP.
You never actually had a childhood.
Oh.
I mean you don't have to go off to my heart like that.
No, no, never.
I'm not, I'm a baby.
You never had a child.
You got to learn.
I saw a drop here.
So there were people.
around here yeah there's people upstairs oh there are across
the where over here on ping two or one sorry there's no ping
yeah I'm paying anything there's ping one no no oh wait wait
wait it's my pin for me I got one I got one okay pet nice
you stole my kill they're not downstairs are they oh no
there's the ammo oh wait there i need that i need his oh
there's a lot of people across northwest across northwest
okay i'm gonna hog around it's a little bit farther there's
lots of lutes up here all right So what's the difference
about cupping mayonnaise and regular mayonnaise?
Is it just cuter or?
It's the way they make it, really.
It's just better.
It's like, yeah, it's just some premium mayonnaise shit.
There's no way to explain it.
It's just better.
Oh my god.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Yeah.
No, no, no.
No, no.
No, I still remember.
Oh shit, there's someone but cross from us.
Yeah.
I saw someone switch to my right.
43, 43.
I got a shield up.
One second.
Oh, Axelion.
Axelion.
Where are you getting shot from?
I don't know if you smoke, really.
The Resn, the Resn.
Resn?
Did you get him?
I think they're upstairs.
Oh no, that he's dead.
Okay, never mind.
I thought he was the Res guy.
Hey.
Where the fuck is he?
I have no idea, but I heard someone I hear so many shots.
I'm gonna go high ground.
We gotta move soon.
Do we?
No, we're fine.
We're chilling.
Up top, up top, up top, on the roof!
On the roof!
Alright, pull back, pull back.
I'm on the roof.
Oh, they dropped down.
Okay, okay.
Okay, because I'm on the roof, I'm on the roof right now i
don't see them they're right up here on ping oh okay they're
so far jesus christ you're so fucking where are these people
that could right blast car
i'm so lost wait patera oh wait he got back that's the guy
we killed earlier
I am like this I'm like this close to sending an artillery
strike on this building and destroying it all like I hate
this building this is Boston dynamics fuck Boston all right
you said it I'm dropping it in nice I hope it destroys this
building nah this building is so strong god damn it god damn
it we gotta go we gotta go we gotta go god damn it oh yeah
we have to go boston knows how to build buildings
i like it when companies are really cool cool offices still
working yeah like twitch has a cool one oh yeah someone's
rising someone's rising oh he's right in front yeah you got
him i i thrusted him Oh, yeah, it's red weapons.
It's a custom weapons.
Go grab it.
Yeah, grab it.
They're really strong.
Yeah, I'm grabbing both.
You have custom weapons.
They must be really good.
LMG.
Oh, my goodness.
They just, okay, cool, cool camp.
On the way?
They are just camping on the top floor.
Careful, careful, Altair.
Okay.
I don't know.
Yeah, yeah, just, just, oh my god.
Cool.
He's on me, he's on me, he's on me.
Oh, shit.
I tried to hit fire.
It was not right.
No!
He's thirsty.
Okay, I have my custom fire.
I have my custom weapon.
Take it.
Mercy little hose.
Oh, my God.
I fucking hit fire.
I should not have hit fire.
No.
I thought, like, hit fire will work on my gun.
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
Okay, or maybe, you know, you can redeploy us.
Oh.
Do we have a redeploy?
I don't think they want you to leave.
All right.
The greatest escape of your life.
Now he run into.
All right.
i believe i believe yeah see there's the closest real place
like oh oh that's oh was that person in front of you yeah
they're getting the weapon drop i think oh god that that's
not just a person that's a tank it's not just the boulder
it's a rock yeah oh my god that's crazy but we turned our oh
it didn't fail like when you're in the tank you see our like
three you're like third person when you're in the tank not
that's crazy i feel like we're fighting forever there holy
shit man i felt like we're shooting for like 20 years this
game hey it's gonna be hard yeah people are gaming today
that's surprising bro a hard one yeah like where am i where
are my babies at Come on.
No, I'm baby.
Where's my fucking babies?
Cue up, children.
You don't have school right now.
It's the weekend.
Cue up.
Come on, slimes.
Go ahead and queue up so we can destroy you.
Where am I weekend queers at?
You don't have school right now.
Oh, thank God we don't have school.
Oh, thank God.
I hated school.
Thank God.
I actually like school a lot.
You like school?
The social part was nice.
Wait, what was your favorite subject?
sports it's not like physical education yeah school that's
not even school well i don't care all the subjects were
saying to me because i was just on my phone and laptop the
whole time just watching youtube videos and you know oh so
you like school because you don't participate in school yes
sir i just go there to meet my friends you know it was just
like a hangout for you you're not yeah it's just a daily
hangout i walk in with my instant noodle inside the
classroom everyone's staring at me like i'm a glorious king
eating noodles they're like i want some noodles too and then
i i you know yeah i just tell the teacher hey you want some
noodles too this noodle kind of spicy yo and then he how
many times did you bring in food to school just like a lot
of food yeah pretty much uh you know like so like school is
basically your daycare yeah kind of did you learn anything
what kind of grades did you get yeah oh uh we don't talk
about that yeah i agree yes i thought you like school I like
the practical part of school, you know, not the theoretical
one class where you get to be practical a physical education
Yeah I like the food tech where you did cooking and shit.
That was fun Yeah, basically fun They would like they would
give us ingredients and they'll be like yeah, they'll be
like Make something with these ingredients you have you have
like 50 it was literally like fucking master chef fucking
shit they were doing you know what the i remember i made a
star a salmon carpaccio i made a salmon carpaccio once that
was the bomb bro how old were you when you made your salmon
carpaccio a 16 maybe oh okay i was gonna say like are you
like were you like 10 or something like make a salmon
carpaccio you 10 year olds calculus in high school i i don't
even use that anymore yeah we got what i was 10 what was i
doing when i was 10.
i'll tell you your jump master i was playing tomodachi
collection when i was like 10 years old nice that's a good
choice you know that came the tomodachi collection you know
that one what else was i playing i'll tell you your jump
master i don't know where you're going though i was pressing
space bar like 20 times it wasn't the point i went to the
chemical diamond and pearl that that one was the bomb
diamond and pearl is the best yo you know you know what was
better than diamond and pearl holy that's so many people so
there's a lot of people there's a lot of people there's a
lot of people and i'm very scared i am very scared we're so
late for the i am so scared and i think i might jump a
little bit better hey guys oh we all decided to be here
that's cool
wait there's trucks with stuff in the back in the back no
these truck these fucking trucks are broke as fuck man they
got what did I get I got a chair it is so bad yeah no what
about you Doki what kind of what kind of class of stuff did
you like did you even like school no no I like the
after-school activities that you get to do after school see
no i was not a fan what the hell is the after school
activity like sports you know like trying oh yeah yeah
sports and stuff and uh yeah sports is fun i used to touch
grass i don't know what happened after yeah i used to be in
varsity teams for sports i still touch grass i still play
ball i don't know you're such a normie yeah i'm an actual
normie you know you're that's crazy how normal you are what
varsity sports did you do i did soccer volley soccer oh my
god oh my god i'm getting shot at i'm getting shot at i'm
getting shot at i don't know where they are second floor
second floor second floor oh you can see him oh i see him
yeah i see him this thing's hard to control this thing yeah
it is not this one though oh i got I almost got it.
I almost got it.
I'm looting.
I'm actually holding.
I did like a hundred on one guy, but I don't know where he
is.
Jesus.
Okay.
We gotta add this guy.
This guy's crazy.
We gotta add him.
There's another team behind us.
There's there's a guy.
There's a guy to our left.
There's a guy to the right.
On top of the roof.
He just jumped out on me.
Artillery strike.
Artillery strike guys.
I got you.
i got you homie yeah thank you i'm waiting i'm waiting i
think i'm gonna be safe i don't think i'm i think i'm safe i
can always count on you finish him oh there's another team
there's another team right here oh my god there's an entire
new team are you kidding me yeah yeah oh my goodness there's
another team there's a full another team guys we no i oh
nice that's okay we have second chance in 19 seconds Coming
up.
Get him, get him.
He's at all.
Okay, he's...
This is kind of nasty, bro.
Whoa.
I still don't know what gun that is.
CLMG.
Hello, don't worry.
I'm coming back.
Don't worry.
We're here.
Oh, my God.
There is another guy.
with me though dude bro he's right here on my body darn
there's another team on us he's tea bagging me oh that's fun
how many people are i killed one i killed one just one just
one okay okay yeah he's half hp i think but it doesn't
matter though he's actually half hp because i think he has
armor i see here i saw gunshots earlier nice I don't see
anyone.
There's someone over here.
That's the gun.
I'm paying the gun, but there's someone over here.
Oh, he's right here, right here.
Oh, shit!
Saw me, saw me.
I'm gonna go from the other way.
What?
What hit me?
The airstrike.
There's an airstrike!
Oh, I had my fucking sniper out.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
I had my sniper out.
Wait, where's R?
Where is he?
Oh, he's over there.
He's coming for you.
He's coming for us.
Mr. Ark.
I'm here.
Please.
Please save us.
Oh my god, Altair's fracking.
Altair's fucking.
He's fucking right now.
We're going.
I'm...
I'm not gonna say that word.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
I'm reproducing!
Yeah!
He's doing it.
He killed some people.
Woo-hoo.
All right.
Oh, hey, P90.
I like that gun in Troubles and Harris Sound.
Is that everybody?
I love that game.
I love P90.
I don't know if it's actually good, but that's my favorite
gun.
P90.
Yeah, I'm just going to get reload.
New map.
mission oh hey oh wait we have some stuff thank you oh hey i
saw rifle i'll grab that i'll grab that where should we go i
don't know i liked our our forfe is really good this piece
is actually dragging out where did you get a baby after
reproduced whoa you got oh you were the mama i'm a fertile
man thank you very much whoa empreg what the are we talking
about i'm gonna like go go go and run with this she's just
in her own land of do you know empreg why does girls always
love watching male get pregnant is it like You like patriots
like shit.
We haven't been through it all these years.
Now it's your turn.
It's fucking now you must feel pain.
Now you must know what it feels like.
Yeah, exactly.
You may have must feel pain now.
You know like how the babies come out of like the booty
walls too?
There's a guy.
Have you ever gotten the kick from the boss?
Hey, I'm on team women's side.
Do I eat hot pot and I take shit every day?
Like that's, you know, I don't think that's like giving
birth.
I do not think that's like giving birth.
I mean, you know, maybe like 10%.
I mean, like, poopy, poopy, poopy.
In front of us.
uh
i gotta heal i gotta heal i gotta heal i gotta kill i gotta
kill we're gonna okay nice oh wait wait oh i nearly killed
that guy too oh what boss one more by the uh by the trucker
i thirsted him that's a whole move right there I don't know
like where...
Oh!
Oh, Air Strike.
Oh, you are...
Yeah.
Oh, that's a different squad.
That's a different squad and air striking.
I was having...
I'm trying to cover him.
...shiver is combat against that guy.
My guy's droning, so I have to cover him.
I'm safe.
You better be safe.
Look at me.
You stay with me.
You want to remember that?
Come on!
Nice.
Because I'm raising you!
Thank you.
I wouldn't.
No, stop calling me M-Preg chat, you fucking weirdo.
I'm not M-Preg Axel.
M-Preg Axel.
Hey guys, skip the sub if you want to be M-Preg.
If you want a what?
If you want an M-Preg Axel.
Whoa!
Guys, a hell no, man.
Have you guys ever seen those like things where like it
simulates like period pains?
Like those little waste things?
That was the boys that tried it.
Yeah.
tried it how did it feel i haven't tried it oh why not just
just do the sack whack the sack like hurts even more doesn't
it just fucking okay but like why have a boy has wait so you
and axel haven't tried it uh not not yet uh lack of
opportunity i mean yeah i'll order it on that i'll give you
okay order it i'll pay you guys order it on amazon what did
i pay you guys i once walked into a chemist like whoa guys
check it out Nice.
I went to a chemist and I was like, you guys have anything
where you can feel fucking like period pain.
And they looked at me like in confusion when I went to the
chemist.
What?
They don't have that shit.
I don't have that shit.
I thought you could just buy it at the fucking chemist, man.
If you go there like- Why would you buy it at the chemist?
You mean the pharmacy?
I don't know.
Yeah, you could get like no- We can't fucking just order it
off the pharmacy.
What the- Just sell it off the counter?
Oh, shit.
They're close to you.
though there they might as well sell you know like period
pain simulator too it's like you know it's close enough 80
similarity that's part of their inventory i have the
inventory stock in the back you know oh wait there's a read
upload tower i'm gonna go go to our chemistry because we're
running out of period simulator too and you guys have like
yeah they didn't have it they said i had to get it on amazon
yes but i was like no i don't want to on amazon i'm old
school you know i'm old You don't want the drones to send
you.
I'm going over to Riz Axel.
Wait, there's someone resing there.
You can hear the...
Here?
Yeah, yeah, look, look.
The tower's moving.
Look, look.
Right in front of you.
That's not him.
Only one person.
Two people.
Wait, no, no.
It's okay.
You can, you can.
No, you can.
No.
Okay.
Nice.
That's not squad white though.
That's not squad white.
There's people behind you.
it's because they res they res that's why oh that's not good
nice cool it's cool you guys i don't even know where i
killed this guy i don't know where oh oh oh wow i don't know
where that was there's another readout tower out there yeah
yeah that's the one i was supposed to go wait where is the
guy killed oh you finished him okay disconnected oh i'm
still getting shot i'm still getting oh my god i'm still
getting shot i'm getting looking shot i'm still getting shot
at see this is why he dropped out of chemistry you know
because chemistry is too hard he's i hate chemistry okay i'm
handing over heading over here whoa i mean shot from my
right oh anal jesus i know that one there's like pain
killers hey anal one it's like somewhere here i was getting
shot at you see him where is he uh 150 south I do not know
where you're shooting it.
He's right by right over here.
Oh, okay.
Is he dead?
He's cracked.
Oh, they're fucking.
He's right by the wall.
Right by the wall.
I see him.
Oh, I'm getting shot by someone else.
Oh, that's a full squad.
It's a full squad.
We got it.
I'm just.
Oh, wow.
Let's get over to the replay.
Yeah, I got this.
I believe in you.
I'm like, oh yeah, chemistry was hard.
You know, biology was the easiest.
physics was my favorite like physics really physics is hard
as well it was just all math it was just all equations you
just plug in man it's easy biology is the easy you just have
to remember like which part of the limb you want to rip off
on someone and then oh did you dissect frogs wait they're
higher they're resting someone oh yeah a sheep's brain oh i
dissected a frog really i detected a like a sheep's oh where
did you go Axel?
Oh, did they think I was like some criminal talking about
Are you checking people?
Where did you go, Axel?
What happened to you?
Maybe the game was like, No, no, you were not allowed to
play the game.
Wait, how did this guy get down?
What?
How did that happen?
We're trying to resurrect Axel and then...
Oh my god, and the axe just disappeared.
It kicked me.
Why?
Yeah, I was going to say, what happened to you?
Maybe I was too much of a menace in the game, you know?
Yeah, that's what I got.
Filtered, maybe.
Just too good.
I don't think I have a...
He's talking about ripping off the limbs and shit.
What's this?
I think I might be dead, boys.
Oh, there you see that?
Yeah, I don't think I'm heading there.
Yeah.
This is what I mean, like, remember?
I was like, oh, you know, when I get on the plane and shit,
I just pray like we don't have research.
I was talking about biology and...
Oh, curious.
shit and then they're like no we're cutting it we're
disconnecting him from the battlefield he's just gonna die
it's just bob just get him yeah because you're like how dare
you kill a sheep yeah exactly but i like lamb a lot lamb
meat is really good yeah i hear people right beside me by
the way so like i hope they don't see me is good though whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa ptsd oh my god war oh my god oh guys you
guys know what is this hey please i think we can make it to
the top five i mean i got i got yeah we got a lot of kills
okay that that art guy was insane though all right we got to
get out of the party though so we could axle that i can't i
don't know how you got kicked out that's crazy i don't know
what happened they were like hating on me yeah the game
hates me bro they're like fuck this game's like he's an
australian man not kick his ass bro i couldn't see i'm
saying a friend request to arc hey arc boy join our squad
all right yeah oh where the hell did he go man yeah i'm
adding we can give you a shower my if you come join us you
get ruthlessly bullied yeah no no depending on how you do
only only alteria is the bully come on what do you mean no
no we all know what you did to that poor man haiti's we all
saw what you did to him i forgot about him we saw what you
did that's so messed up you're right wait he's still playing
wait he's still playing but he just like left us he's
actually so funny all right qa who's up okay one shawarma
please uh i didn't set accept my friend request i'm sad what
if i what if he was a big streamer i can message him add
friend quick message let's play again soon i sent him a
message I was like, let's go.
Let's play again soon.
I'm going to send him one too.
You suck.
Yeah.
There's like a quick message thing.
I'll send him one too.
One shawarma, please.
Yeah.
We all send him a message.
Maybe I'll accept it.
One V one.
I'm going to rest.
He's going to report him for harassment.
No, we can't be.
Wait.
Where's...
Okay.
We can't be reported for harassment if we each send him one
message.
Maybe even two messages from each of us.
but i'm asking him for a shawarma that he's gonna report me
for harassment there's no way we're just being really men
don't have the same muscles that stimulate that get
stimulated during periods so they're kind of scams wait but
then okay well the women have pain simulators of ball sack
like ball sack pain simulators do they have that i don't
think i think i don't think that's possible should we kick
jokey and try oh okay like you know what you're knowing like
i know how to self-defend It's a science.
It's science.
Like, you attack your ball sack and then, like, a simulator
and then you hit that, and then it, like, imitates the
damage.
The damage?
Oh, yeah.
To cancel your bloodline.
Oh, why am I, like, a control variant?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll find someone else to do that for us.
Why?
Any volunteers?
We are, like, the scientists, observe.
We're not the participants, guys.
have xx is his name yeah he's born on he's 69 nice on the
69th day of april nice you can tell that you can tell he's
not a zoomer because it's not 67.
you know we could have gone this entire collab without
saying that i was what is up with american people in 67 man
i have no idea where it came it's from like
It's it's it's something it came from a rapper but then it
came from some chat on TikTok and he does like the hand
thing like the six seven six seven.
Oh, you know, I found out.
Okay.
So like Marvel Rivals recently had like this the land the
finals land where it was like a million dollars and then
they were doing like team introduction and one of the teams
everyone was like six seven like as their team intro and I
was like what the and I asked about it.
Apparently it was like the it was like the media person who
directed the intro they'd be like guys we gotta do something
fun and relatable why don't you guys start doing six seven
as your team intro and i was like and the relatable and then
the day became the villains of the esports world yeah
they're like guys we got these guys why don't we guys do
something funny and relatable why don't you do the six seven
pose for your team intro so you guys see the i think it was
you guys check out the dark zero um the dark zero team intro
for the land and you see all of them who the six seven that
was because of the media person that told them they did not
it was not like it was not consensual so that's what it
means to be pr trained now it's not consensual six seven
they not they are trained They were told they were told to
do it.
Ooh, a sniper.
Ooh, what do we consume?
I have a...
The brain rot is consuming everyone.
Hey, I had probably never watched Skippity Toilet, so I
think I'm...
I think I'm doing okay.
I had the Skippity Toilet backpack on Fortnite.
I paid for it.
You and I were...
We are not the same.
I'm better.
I'm... I'm hip with the kids.
Why shouldn't they give us that?
memes i missed the good old memes you know okay no no each
generation has my dudes each generation has their own
cringe-ass memes what was my cringe-ass meme every
generation has a up meme like i i mean like there was there
was e like that one that i don't know how the that one got
popular if it wasn't markiplier i don't think it would have
blown up
It's still not working.
Oh yeah, and then I can has cheeseburger.
And then troll-lo-lo.
You mad.
You mad?
What was the?
Mi-gusta?
Okay, Mi-gusta was pretty.
Mi-gusta.
Mi-gusta was pretty pretty.
Troll-lo-lo-lo.
Troll-lo-lo-lo-lo.
I mean, trolling, rage bait is basically new gen trolling.
Yeah, rage bait is basically a new gen trolling.
he's literally just trolling yeah rage bait is new gen
trolling that's literally what it means it's just what do
you think is more derogatory though rage bait or troll i
think trolling is just it it doesn't age well the tournament
is just not as good i think yeah i i'd actually argue the
opposite i think trolling is actually doing okay no it's
it's kind of like for fun but then but rage baiting you you
you thrive off the suffering for the people and that's a
little bit too much no i love the word gaslighting that's my
favorite oh gaslighting me too it's like basically
manipulation but like but it sounds nice
despite going i remember when i first debuted our management
was like so don't use the word gaslighting it's not a good
word wait what really and i'm like really careful at the
beginning yeah and i'm like stop trying to gaslight me man
it's not a bad it's like the overwatch league where they
said nope they weren't allowed to use the pepe frog because
they thought it was like a really offensive infantry people
were like penalized if they used a pepe frog not pepe man
yeah yeah and then i remember like uh some overwatch players
they got like uh they have to pay fines if they start
t-bagging people that was crazy that's the though yeah let's
make rivalries let's make storylines i know this is
happening overwatch right here i don't know they see me they
don't see me by the way they're just walking in front of me
i'll wait for you guys i prone hey i didn't know that chat
yeah some people got people were getting fine left and right
for teabagging.
There's a guy on the roof.
You see him?
Oh, yeah, you definitely saw it.
Yeah.
I'm blanking this guy.
Oh, wait.
I just realized I am not part of this fight because I don't
see...
I don't know where the entrance is.
Okay, guys.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm finding the door.
I'm still trying to find the door.
I'll take this.
Alright, guys.
Got knocked.
I don't know how.
On my way, on my way.
Can I knife this?
Oh, I can knife the tarp?
Okay, guys.
I figured it out.
See you?
You got him?
Alright, I'm almost there, guys.
I just...
i lost all my god he prone coming out okay we're coming i'm
coming i'm coming over too my headline missed everything
i'm here i'm here he's one hp no where is he he's using my
crouching strap somewhere over there it's okay i got you
thank you thank you don't worry
where is he wait how did you wait you're fine where is the
guy uh he ran probably like a little bit oh wait no you got
one yay stole the gun sorry all right so i took the longest
flank of my life and i totally yeah i came back with milk
and eggs yeah i came back as with milk So I didn't realize,
you know, the green tarp fences?
I thought, like, I couldn't melee that because, you know,
there's a fucking fence on top.
There's, like, a green tarp on it, you know?
I was like, bro, there's a tarp on it.
There's no way I can knife that.
That's a very strong-ass tarp.
You just gotta believe in yourself, Doki.
I did not believe in myself.
You just gotta believe.
Oh!
Air strike, air strike, air strike!
That's fine.
I'm in a good place.
Who did do that?
Oh!
Are you okay?
Yeah.
Wait, where did that airstrike come from?
I don't see anyone.
Axel, did you airstrike out there?
Nah, nah.
If it's your allies, they'll be green, you know?
You can tell the difference between green and red.
Oh, I didn't see the color.
I don't see color.
Wow.
So you blind.
Yeah, yeah.
It's okay, we're all the same.
We're VTubers.
Yeah, exactly.
We're all the same.
You blind, mute, and the death.
I cast a spell where you become blind, mute, and death.
And you lose your limbs.
No, and you lose bones.
Like, I'll...
You can keep your limbs, but I'm gonna take away the bones.
I might as well keep like fucking...
Like, how do I eat?
You don't.
Like, one of my slimes.
Oh, that's true.
I can be...
I can reincarnate into a slime, like that one anime.
card name to my biggest fan oh okay no but that's not fair
so i'm going to i'm going to catch another spell where uh
you have no wealth like your family has no wealth so you're
starting point is yeah i don't want to go back oh no okay
but like but like do i go back in time or like it is it like
2025 is it is it like a year oh oh guys guys i'm four i
gotta shop by something it was but i'm jumping i'm jumping
people people people nice i'm down i'm down oh my god oh my
god my god my second chance is just oh wait no no we all
second chance that was crazy i was not expecting like a car
to run over axle and then a fucking tank showing up right
after that was crazy people know that we're here careful
we're here we're so freezing yeah there is someone rising
it's like it's so loud Come on, come on, come on.
They're in the entire tank, Maja.
It's the engineer.
I got him.
Nice.
Did he get the res off?
I don't know.
Yeah, he did.
Well, now we gotta kill his friends, don't we?
I see him.
I got sniped.
West, west, west, across the street.
I don't care.
I'm killing this guy.
Oh, on the house.
On the building.
God.
Whoa.
I don't see him.
I'm gonna get another angle.
Fuck did he go?
I don't know, but that's a... that's that.
I'm getting closer to the house.
What?
Okay.
What happened to my parachute?
Bro, he's so far.
I'm not getting to him.
I need oh wait you got someone where where is he there's
people on that house across the street yeah yeah actually
you just killed someone or was I just tripping oh yeah I
killed someone somehow oh wait our guy got snipped yeah I
got his ass okay I'm gonna do something really crazy but I
don't think they're looking they're pretty low wait where on
the house you're not like close to me okay I'm well I'm up
I'm actually like next to the house now I can move up
because I'm running out of snip sniper ammo oh they aren't
coming oh I'm trying to figure out how to get up here I'm
gonna go from behind there's no way they expect me from
behind watch this I might Wow.
Wait, what?
Oh, no.
They just have a sniper rifle that can hit every round, I
guess.
I don't know where they are.
I'm here.
I'm safe.
I'm safe here.
Okay.
Oh, he's one.
He's one.
Can you rescue Mr. NPC?
Please, please.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Oh, he dropped down.
He dropped down.
Okay.
Oh, wait, what?
He's solo!
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Ooh.
Oh, you made it to us.
Right below us.
Oh, they're both.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's not fine.
It is not fine.
It is so not fine.
Oh no.
What is the zip here?
Oh my god, bro.
That guy was crazy though.
He was hitting nasty eyes shots.
I'm watching him.
What the fuck is a zip on this building?
Oh my god.
Give me a zip line somewhere.
Wait, he knows his utility.
Oh, never mind.
He's dead.
It's up to you.
It's one guy left.
It's one guy.
Trust me.
Axel's serious.
It's really unfortunate.
But you're our only hope.
Oh, wait.
No, you just read.
I don't like that.
Actually, just read us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's near the edge of the zone.
I believe in you.
Oh, yeah.
No, you're not going to make it.
You're not going to make it.
There's no one right over here south of you.
You know what?
Do it.
Just give it a shot, shall we?
You know what?
I'm an Australian.
I live with the bushfire.
Exactly.
You live with the bushfire.
You're so used to it.
Yeah, this is just like it's another Saturday morning for
me, you know?
Yeah.
No.
I believe.
It's another Saturday morning.
And I'm American.
I got shot a lot.
Oh.
You're so fine.
Hee.
Don't burn.
Don't worry.
It's just a little five won't turn anybody.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, it's actually.
close it's too close it's too close it's too close no you're
a coward Axel I ain't no coward you're a coward you were
literally two seconds away three seconds away from death
okay Axel seems runs away again with full health yep runs
away like a like a little bitch you know you could you could
regen HP that you can reach i hope someone is waiting
outside that gate right there at the edge of the zone and
just shoot you in the face that's right i said i hope that
you survive and thrive i don't you know me i'm the goat you
are the goat yeah axol you're the goat i hope oh does he
gonna see you gonna get it watch him come on the last second
yeah watch him like Right here, right there.
Oh!
Boss!
Bro, I don't even know.
Where the hell are these people?
Where did you even get shot?
He got shot from where he came from.
Oh, so someone's behind him.
Bro, what?
Someone was behind him?
How the fuck?
Yeah, that's a goddamn rat.
Alright, I'm sending a friend with us to the other guy.
Someone will.
Someone will want to put him.
Oh, he didn't accept my friend request.
What do we...
Instant denial?
No, the other guy.
I'm going to add this guy.
X9veg 0.
I'm going to send him a quick message too.
Today another?
Hit him with a knee, how sir?
Yeah, I did a quick message.
I'll send this other guy a quick message too.
View profile.
Social menu.
Quick message.
Let's start a group.
Say it.
I bet we can get top five.
I believe in us.
Axel, you want a game yet?
Huh?
Have you won a game yet?
Me?
No?
Okay.
I believe you.
Okay, I'm playing half the time drunk, okay?
Leave me alone.
Are you drunk right now?
No, I'm asleep.
I'll give you that.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
I mean, that's the same thing.
Hey, leave me alone.
You know, I'm just a guy.
I'm just like one of those dads who came back from the nine
to five job.
And then I just want to enjoy my game.
And I'm getting, you know, I'm fighting.
Yeah, I'm just getting no life is relentlessly bullied by
your teammates.
I don't know.
How could they do this?
Unbelievable.
All right.
We have ASAP Jojo.
I believe in him.
He's level 55.
So he's been playing since launch.
Wow.
ASAP Jojo.
Yeah, Father 3 returns home from work just to get shit on by
Why is he called ASAP Jojo?
Maybe he likes Powerpuff Girls.
Maybe he's a rapper.
Yeah, oh yeah, that's true.
He has a dollar sign on his name.
That's Pete Rapper.
Axel's a rapper.
Really are?
You are?
Yo, rappers.
Axel, they call me Eminem.
Yeah, do you give us an Eminem song?
Nobody calls you Eminem.
a freestyle.
No, I don't do freestyles, you know?
No, no freestyles from me.
Ooh, I do what you do?
I can't tell you what it feels like.
I can only tell you what really is I said axle, not out
there.
Oh, rapper, but like, see?
That's like asking a millionaire, hey, show me the million
dollars you got.
Millionaires don't do that.
That's why they're millionaires.
You don't have to show.
They can just they show by their clothes and their cars.
Where's your clothes and cars?
Well, I'm a rapper.
Where's your rhymes and skim?
Yeah, where's your rhyme?
Oh, potatoes, tomatoes, the hose, the...
The what?
Let's go downtown.
Come on, Jojo, take us to downtown.
No, that's fine.
You can take us to...
Oh, no, he...
Oh, where is he taking us?
I don't know.
Where is he taking us?
Where is this?
Or he wants to loot these shit houses.
Where did he take us?
I don't even know where he took us.
It scares the crap out of me every time.
Yeah.
I don't even know where he took us.
It's just some fucking random house.
A nice safe neighborhood.
On somebody's house.
Well, I don't think they're living here anymore.
Yeah, this does not look very safe for a neighborhood.
I'm a cheat kit.
I have this.
Oh, another MC too.
I have a little engineer thing for you.
Engineer thing?
Aww.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll take it.
It's for you to open up for us.
On my way.
I bet your rent here is pretty cheap, though.
Helicopter!
Close to us.
Me keeping the rent cheap in my neighborhood.
starts firing fucking rounds of make a date make if you make
your neighborhood a dangerous neighborhood the rent will
always be cheap pro tip life hack you guys are horrible
people
don't you have morals it's affordable morals morals in this
economy hell no we're here we're we're here to control the
rent you know making sure that the landlords can't raise
property value and the property is dangerous they can never
raise the value true yeah just like if there's a death in
the in the in the lot in no i think like you know i feel
like you know real estate agents don't tell you if someone
died in your in in the home so you might have like i don't
know you might have five generations of murderers who lived
there before yeah why show me the house facts okay why the
fuck would they tell you that someone died in the home if
they're trying to sell it you know it's not lying they're
they're not lying if they're omitting information above why
is there a guy here i don't know what but he's hurting yeah
he's just right over there because the thing is like would
you ever ask like a real estate agent like how many people
have died in this home like that's not a normal question to
ask so they don't have to like have you ever asked yeah
shinri would you have a sick bastard yeah shinri shinri's
interested in that kind of stuff he's looking for a ghost
yeah so oh oh that's oh okay okay i mean i guess we can
casually outing out our direct yeah i'm just like all right
like that's neat i guess also i see people where there's two
teeth there's a full team here Okay.
We shot.
What?
Wait, I have an airdrop or airstrike.
This guy has no armor, by the way.
I'm already hit 47 on him.
Oh my god.
Oh, they- That's a big airstrike.
Yeah, they airstrike us.
No, that's me.
That's me.
I just- Oh, go.
You airstrike us.
Okay.
It's a big- it's a big explosion radius.
If I- okay, I got hit by that.
I got hit by your airstrike.
Skill issue, skill issue.
Oh, oh, oh man, I'm getting shot at now.
Across at the tree?
It's a 40, 16?
Like, yeah.
Behind us, behind us, behind us, behind us.
Behind us, okay.
Yeah, up the hill, up the hill.
Oh, I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
At the, at the, uh, cell phone tower.
Radio tower?
What is it?
Oil thing?
No, that's the that's the radio tower.
I'm pretty sure I'm slowly walking up this Wait, where are
you shooting at?
I don't see anyone out there They're definitely there reach
line reach line reach line left side left side left side Oh
shit.
Oh shit.
I need a heal.
I knocked someone though I'm hurt.
I'm not I didn't lock someone, but like I oh my gosh.
I don't have his I'm covering you Oh, shit.
Wait, is there someone behind you?
Is there someone behind you?
No, we just got hit.
Okay, okay.
I'm heading over
I'm just a little greedy.
Are you safe?
All right, safe, safe, safe.
They're not pushing Oh, we're good Whoa, it's a full squad.
It's a full squad.
Oh my god, you are crazy What how did he not die boss got
one got one got one?
It's up to you.
You're one HP and it's up to you
Thank you Lisa Oh, no, oh I bled it's okay.
I have second chance We all have second chance, I think so
apparently it's like a police officer if you ask they have
to disclose But they don't have to tell you.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
They don't have to tell you police officer So they can omit
information about murders in the home Because they're trying
to sell at home.
Why the fuck would they tell you?
Like, there's no reason.
It's okay.
I don't think I'll ever own a home, so we'll see.
Are you kidding me?
What is up with people?
Yeah, but maybe the apartment you're in right now is a
murder home.
You don't know that.
I hope no one got murdered in my family home.
Whoa.
Yeah, who owned it before your family?
Freshly built home.
yeah but who used to live in that property before you whoa
it was an empty lot whoa yeah but someone can die in an
empty lot it could be a native american burial ground you
don't know that that's you know that is a good point yeah it
could always be i don't like i don't like how you can
convince me so easily what if there was a war bot in that
lot empty lot what if you wanted to
Let's meet up.
Oh, behind you guys, behind you guys.
In between you.
Oh, this is a sniper.
Hey, there's a guy right here.
Oh, I hate this gun.
Across the street, there's a person.
Okay, okay.
I don't have ammo.
Oh, my God.
I will call me.
Oh my god, okay.
I had, like, just a sniper rifle.
Axel, guys, nice.
I believe in Axel.
I bursted one of them, so they can't rest the other.
Oh.
Boy, it's no fucking.
Oh, my god.
It's so fast.
What the fuck?
He just locks on like that.
Yeah, that's, yeah.
No, he just had a...
I bet the light doesn't help you.
I did not help that I had a sniper.
It really is.
Okay, I'm not adding this guy.
20th place.
Guys, we improved.
Yeah.
we definitely i don't understand it's saturday where are my
children at we're we're all asleep there's no way there's no
way they're asleep on a saturday it's like it's like 9 28 p
.m what the fuck what they're weak these new these zoomers
are so weak now wait do you see that guy underneath the map
yeah i also do yeah yeah okay okay no this This guy's
hacking.
And he's gone.
Yeah.
This guy was hacking.
Whoa, what the hell was that?
He's Mr. Cheater right there, bro.
Bro, how are they not on our team?
I don't...
Yeah, we get like trapped and then shit, right?
Yeah, he doesn't want to play with us.
There's that.
Yeah, no, that was a hacker straight up.
Oh, wait.
It's Gen Alpha now.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Where are my Gen Alphas?
Oh, wait.
what the is that that's the one after zoomers you know how
like everything is like the one's gonna be after gen alphas
i think there was already a gen like i don't i think there
is a name after gen alpha it's gen beta i think is it gen
mate is it beta imagine being a beta where the is where is
winfield oh my god wait level 204 i'm accepting guys the
level 204 like added us okay i'm adding him in get in here
winfield field get the in here you're in level 24 you get
your ass in here oh leave your game leave your game right
now he's in the game oh he left wait he left his game ain't
no way ain't no way I literally watched him leave his game
oh my god he's in he's in get in get he's in queue up 243
Bro, this guy is 204 If he's not carrying us Like Then Then
we're at one carryable No, he's not like He looks like a
pumpkin bro What the fuck?
Why are you like orange and shit?
Bro, if he can't carry us Like we're not meant to get
carried Shit Like we're just Like there's no saving us
There's no hope for us Oh my Top five We have to get top
five There's We have to get top five At that point point
maybe we should have purchased more like pubg instead of
like warzone but this is more more more more more okay i
want to see this to level 200 and port guy which one is bro
he has a is that custom bro he has a custom skin and
everything he's a pumpkin oh my god he is a pumpkin bro how
much money did you spend on that and that guy looks so cool
and then my character looks like he's I look like I just I
look like I just like got out of college and sign up for the
army my character looks like Johnny Yeah, I got paid
tuition.
Oh, yeah, no, I I like I joined the army to pay for tuition.
That's what I look like I was almost going to the army
really what happened?
If I didn't get into my dream school my at least a decent
school for college then I would have gone to the army sector
were you planning ongoing i was really crazy i was gonna go
marines if i could bro what you're gonna get jacked up that
was gonna be cool imagine imagine the alternate timeline we
just all two sounds like this but i could have been okay
yeah hey everyone i mean at that time i was doing like so
many sports i was doing you know martial arts and everything
so i was in good shape that's crazy and then and then you
started playing video games my condolences yeah i became a
vtuber then you started liking anime i saw youtube these
vtubers from hololife productions and i was like huh i could
be a vtuber too all right let's go i'm following win winfred
winifred that's his name right yeah he got he got an igl for
us yeah he got igl bro winfield Use Mike.
IGL us.
You got Mike?
Anyone got mics?
Please carry.
I love the mic button.
All right.
We're going to the Lyndon Oil Works, are we?
Lyndon Oil Works.
I believe in him.
Yeah, I mean, if this is where I can meet my oil baron.
Actually, you're getting your first win today.
Yes, sir.
This is it.
is the 3d printing place the 3d printing place or the cool
area remember the place you got stuck at oh yeah yeah yeah
where i should say like nuke that building like that
building yeah you should have sexual relations with that
building what that's what you said right you wanted to you
wanted to act that building oh you kind of you kind of weird
i did not have relations with that building whoa you're kind
of freaky bro you're kind of you know it's like the worst of
me it's like that it's like that you know like my strange
addiction where that guy fucked his car and like married it
uh why i didn't know you guys don't know about like my
strange where where are you okay my strange addiction we're
like i know of it but okay so there was an ep bro that
episode was famous guys not know and then like you have to
like confess to his dad that he was in love with his car and
his dad was not happy apparently i don't know why like don't
you're listening to two people who watch breaking bad within
the last couple years okay we're a little bit we're a little
bit uh slow i haven't even watched breaking back yet though
oh you should no i just see the pressing is this guy oh how
many people are oh you're dead never mind i'm gonna say
location echo yeah ping their location for us it's back
we're actually dead some over here Wait, what?
Wait.
Oh, shit.
Our other guy died already.
Wait, what the fuck?
Bro, you're level 204.
No, wait a minute.
Oh.
I see him.
First floor, first floor.
Wait, first floor.
Oh, shit.
Oh, there's artillery, artillery, artillery, artillery,
artillery.
I am... I have to scratch my nose.
I am out of the range now.
there's a lot holy why are so many airstrikes yo i'm a flank
the ass shit i only had a pistol never mind i'm going back
wait there's stuff over here there's stuff over here axel
you're getting the flank that what happened and he ran away
one dead one dead one dead and he ran away okay i'm coming
over i had to get Yeah, wait for me to get to the restrike.
On my body, on my body.
I'm coming all over.
Oh, no.
We thirsted you.
I died so quick.
Hey.
Wait, who's that?
Oh, wait.
That's the...
I got you, homies.
That's right.
We thirsted him for you.
Thank you.
I always can count on my friends if you're thirsting and
killing people for me.
Yeah.
don't worry we always do it for our homies yeah get a get a
homie that will kill for you oh god there's two over there I
have to grab armor I'm back yeah he's in yeah I'm good I'm
taking my second armor in they're resing to our left by the
way oh I can't see shit I can't see shit now oh shit I can't
see shit.
How the fuck is he?
Oh my god!
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know.
But they're crazy.
They're crazy.
Why is there fucking smoky here?
Holy shit.
Yeah, yeah, they're crazy.
On top of him.
On me, on me, on me, on me.
Okay, come here.
There's two on me.
I'm gonna throw this.
I don't know where he is, but he's on me You're surrounding
us, I think it's the southwest.
I mean, I mean, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, yeah!
Oh, there's two of them.
Second floor, first floor, second floor, first.
Ah!
Yeah, he's got it.
You guys got it.
What?
He was on the corner.
Oh, that's okay.
He chased us.
Up top, up, top.
That's okay.
I still have second life.
I have my second life.
Maconachos.
That's amazing.
If he downs me, I have my second life.
I feel like, watch this.
Okay, not yet, but it'll be there in 25 seconds.
Oh my god.
They are crazy with the aim, these guys.
It's okay.
I'm coming over.
I'm dead.
Oh god, this is not where I want to drop.
Okay, um, we are gonna head over here.
There's two redeploy is right next to you yeah i'm heading
all the way to the other side bring it around town You think
there's a save?
It's not safe!
I'm... goodbye.
You can do this, chicken man.
It was absolutely not safe.
I saw a guy literally just walk over there last minute.
He could have killed him.
I believe...
No, no, no.
I think he had a team, guys.
no i couldn't be yeah you're right oh my leggies i twisted
my ankle guys you like my legma my ligma don't worry i'll
buy those crystals they'll cure my ligma the shut night
right how ligma curing crystals get yours now contact regis
altair and actual serious to get scanned yeah wait what
about me guys i can also scan people too we're the scammers
you're the you're the i'm the distributor i'm the
distributor distributor yeah yeah i'll distribute the scams
so they can't scam now joki will deliver it to you right
away no no no no i give it to you guys and then you know how
like uh when you're when you know during like uh when you're
dealing like drugs and stuff you know there's like the
supplier and then the you guys are in the alleyway and the
supplier okay see you look like you would like yeah exactly
i've never watched that is good you the uh salamanca i'll be
like that that paint that guy that guys have his face blown
up oh that's great who's yeah i'm that guy who i'm far you
can be styler white no no i even i know she's a yeah no no
no no She's Skylar White, yo.
Everyone knows she's a bitch.
You can be Ted to them.
You can be Ted.
Oh, is that the sun?
Is that the sun?
No, that's Walter Jr. Wait, wait, wait.
It's a cheating CR.
Oh, wait, wait.
Behind us, behind us, right here.
Head up.
We got a danger point.
I don't know.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I got a sniper.
Fuck.
This guy's butt cheeks.
It was mine.
I got him.
My gun might be butt cheeks, but I still got you.
Boy.
Mr. butt cheeks.
Whoa!
I don't know where his teammates are.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, there's some stuff here.
Where are his teammates, though?
Right here, people?
He's probably resting, so maybe just one around us.
Yeah.
I don't know where he is.
I'm checking this out.
Is there any good shit here, girl?
Where do we go?
Oh, definitely not towards the fire.
Let's go northeast.
Northeast?
All right.
I'm following Altair.
If we die is because of him, he has a bad leadership.
Woohoo!
I'm a bad leader.
Follow me, guys.
We're gonna die.
Yippee!
Oh, okay.
That's scary.
We're gonna go towards combat training, actually.
I feel like, should we loot here?
Oh, sure.
I'm getting my knife out.
I'm shaking the wall.
Wall has been successfully...
Oh, they looted this area.
This area has nothing.
Leader, you have a guild of six to lead.
Yeah, but we could always have more.
Yeah, there's nothing here, though.
Oh, you fuck.
Are you guys okay?
Wait, wait, where are you getting shot at?
I'm about to die, yo.
Where did you get shot at?
Oh, this?
I have no idea.
Helicopter.
Okay.
Wait, where are you?
Up the hill.
Up the hill west.
Hill west.
West, west, west, west.
Okay.
I'm looking at the hill.
This guy just creeps.
crouching I'm still looking at the hill I don't think
looking anyway I don't see anyone up there I'm still looking
there's nobody there mm-hmm they may have backed off yeah
they're little pussies you don't have to call them that just
got it backed off strategically strategically in a straight
line now you ain't punished just know that everybody has a
reason for for doing everything including running away
cowardly nope I just running away from responsibilities my
favorite things to do I'm not used any of the grenades yet
you want to try no okay check it out
wait the grenades don't you friend oh no you lost your armor
what did it did it on armor wait did it actually hurt you
now no no no oh wait the grenades don't do What's the point?
What's the point in the maze?
Don't blow up your friend's legs.
Let's stop playing this game.
This game's boring.
Yeah.
What's the point if you can't blow up your friend's legs?
Like, what the fuck?
That's what life is all about.
I know.
It's about killing your friends and taking away their limbs.
Exactly.
I should get your butt cheeks over here.
Hurry up.
Exactly.
It's gonna be a while.
There's still 16 more.
Should we stay in like the hills?
Oh, no.
We gotta find better loot, that's for sure.
I think someone just parachuted behind us south.
Wait, really?
Yeah, Winfred is...
I saw a parachute cut off.
There he is.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's peeing someone over there.
Careful, Axel.
They're shooting at us.
I don't know which one was my long scope, but...
Look at how they're hitting everything, hey.
Hey!
That's fucking wild.
kind of crazy that pretty weird you're kind of stuck over
there for a while why is this game so hot you make it hard
so you want the wind more
what axel gets next that's crazy it's okay thank you it's
okay I'm proning I'm proning let's get over let's let's all
go somewhere yeah I don't think I like being in the open
here should we get the top maybe maybe I'm using my knife to
run faster just because I'm carrying less equipment yeah
yeah fine of course the level 200 has our armor let's hug
this side of the of the mountain maybe we can oh play the
hill Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, bro, chill.
I'm serpentine, I'm serpentine.
Oh, there's a small divot right here, small divot.
Oh, there we go.
Can't shoot me when I'm in a hole.
All right, now I can chill.
Yeah, I can chill right now.
Whoa.
We are not in the zone.
We're relaxed.
Oh, okay, never mind.
I guess we don't chill.
I didn't want to chill anyway.
I didn't want to chill.
I'm gonna keep bordering the outside right over here on the
west side yeah that's a good idea because there shouldn't be
anybody from out here I believe yeah it looks pretty safe
yeah I don't see anyone on the outside I think we're five
hello everybody hello are you cool are you all cool I sure
hope they are Check your mission.
Oh, shit.
You guys are.
You guys already went down.
Ow!
I got sniped.
Oh, that's not cool.
Same people south.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I'm going to fall right into this right now.
Let's find a place and hold up.
I'm going to win.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Winfield!
Oh my god.
You got shot.
You got shot by him.
You got the bazooka was went past me and then it killed the
shot him.
That was crazy.
Oh my god, I got stuck The tank Just blew up the house Okay,
he doesn't, they don't know The tank will not, guys there's
no way the tank will know I'm in here I mean, there's people
in that house right over here as well Guys guys guys guys
guys guys Yeah, yeah Guys, I think the tank is right here
You got this I think the tank is right here guys It's so
scary.
It's okay, I'm here too.
No, it's okay.
No, you...
Oh, this feels dead too.
Altair?
I'm getting a shot.
It's scary outside.
What the fuck was I watching?
Bro, Altair!
They're all gonna fucking come for us!
Oh, wait, yeah, I'm thinking shields, though.
I think it's a glitch to shield.
I can't pick it up.
Oh, no.
Oh.
It's okay.
I think we're very, very safe.
You and I, we're like, we're like slimes right now.
We're just like slugs.
Don't worry.
I have, what is this?
What's my four?
I have something on my four, but I don't know what it is.
Guys, what's my four?
What is that?
What is four?
It's your ability.
What's my ability?
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
You think I know what?
Oh shit.
I just lost consciousness there for like 10 seconds.
Holy shit.
Oh shit.
You okay?
Oh yeah.
I might have to call this as the last one maybe.
Shit.
My consciousness is flying right now.
Don't worry.
Don't worry Axel.
We will get you.
Oh my god.
He's right here.
I was there!
You left me for one second!
I was on the other side!
Oh my god!
I...
He killed them!
I thought that was...
I thought that was all there!
Is it here?
Alright, Axel, how about...
Oh, unlucky!
Oh my god, we are so close.
Axel, how about...
One more.
You got this.
You got it.
We got six points.
almost hit the next one the next one is top five out one
more one more one more no more i'm losing my we got him we
got him and then after that game we'll be like come on axel
one more we were so i'm gonna disappear i'm gonna go buy
milk no no no no axel come back one more no axel play one
more come on come on last one for real for real for real
this one's last one axel this one's We're gonna get your
first win right now.
I'm locking in for real this time.
No, I'm gonna lock in for real.
No conversations about killing people.
No conversation about...
We're locked in.
We're so locked in.
We're gonna try for you.
We weren't trying before, but this time we will.
Yeah, I was using my left hand.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I had to monitor off this entire time.
I was using my...
I was playing my character bullet and using my ears to play.
I was slaving this entire time.
guys shall now know the fear of oh my god locked in lock in
axa all right lock in we're locking in lock in no one will
make you lock in axa do you drink like two cups of caffeine
no i don't know before you chug in those five hours yeah two
cups of caffeine and a five hour energy drink That's seven
hours of energy, right?
Yeah, yeah, that's seven hours!
Coffee for hours!
I gotta do caffeine, sir.
Yeah, oh, and then if you get like, you know, if you get
too, like, caffeinated, just calm it down with alcohol.
It like counteracts.
By the way, that's a joke, guys.
Don't do that.
Guys, for legal reasons, that is a joke.
Do not mix alcohol and caffeine together.
I mean, some do, but like, don't do it.
Isn't it gonna be, like, hyper...
It's gonna kill you.
Well, it's sort of like...
i mean there's red bull and vodka yeah that's what they do
like there's also like bayleys you know like uh cat coffee
and uh liquor i actually didn't order a bayleys because i
thought it was a regular drink um and and i had to i was in
new york city so i had to like walk back to my hotel at 9 p
.m not sober at all they named it after bailey he died
drinking too much i thought it was like regular coffee
because they're like oh i was like they're like because like
it was my first time in a nice fancy restaurant and at their
like i was just like oh this drink looks very expensive i'm
gonna order this and they didn't id check me too so i didn't
realize that what it was yeah so i i was just like i didn't
realize it was alcoholic i'll be at a fun time in new york
city i love that place yeah it was fun and i drank the and i
drank i realized it was alcohol and i was like bro it was
like so expensive so i was like might as well drink the
entire thing like i was like It was like $40 plus dollars.
I might as well.
$40 drink.
Yeah, it was a $40 drink.
So it's like, holy shit, that's a fancy-ass drink.
I don't know why I didn't fucking think it was alcohol.
Let's go somewhere a little different.
Let's go here.
Who's the fourth in their squad?
I don't know.
He was level 200, and we adopted him.
Well, you don't know Winfield VTuber?
Oh, shit, you're right.
No, Winfield, the pro gamer.
This guy has...
It's basically...
He's part of VSM.
Yeah, you know, like the...
The I can solo her guy?
That's basically him.
Team team team.
Oh, shit.
It's not him, but he's like...
He's like that guy, but for...
For battlefield.
I got one guy.
With my T-Fog.
T-Fog.
The guy with my pistol.
Good job, Winfield.
Winston.
Winfieldston.
Good job, bro.
Nice.
See, Axel, this is what a real veteran would do.
Yeah.
You would know.
He almost became a veteran.
Yeah, but in the name of the law.
It's not murder when you're doing it for their country.
It's not murder if you're doing it for content.
That's true.
That too.
You're protecting everyone.
Guys, there's a lot of people here, and I only have my
pistol.
What the fuck?
No audio, cool, battlefield, Apex Legends 2?
Oh, no.
Okay.
Guys, I still have my pistol.
Stick game, guys.
Winfield's dead.
Axel's dead.
Give me a second.
Um.
I still have my pistol against someone.
So all my guns.
There's just no audio whatsoever.
My teammates may or may not have stolen my guns.
Stolen.
It's a battle, yeah.
Goes to Steam Store page.
Rates it one star.
no audio okay it's fine do you know what this means no one
more hell no it's okay it's okay I still live it's okay I'm
still alive I'm not no longer alive oh my god I believe you
doki what happened why would you do that wait wait you did
not have a gun this is so cringe it's okay it's okay i am
alive this is so cringe oh wait altera is also alive okay
you gotta go find a res for us okay first one we find a res
that's uh well you're the only one alive windfield no
windshield died in front of me he um made a little oopsie by
landing on a person that had a gun oh So you made a little
bit of an oopsie daisy You're back I'm Going You're going to
the redeploy right Hi Alright you go to that redeploy I go
to the next redeploy just in case I'm on a bridge Oops One
of us is going to get this redeployed Actually no I'm going
to live Oh my god oh my god Oh my god there's people There's
people There's people.
There's people.
Bye-bye, Doki.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Thank God.
Oh my God.
Okay, okay.
Okay, we're fine.
There is like an entire squad right behind me.
I'll just tell you that.
It's a helicopter!
Oh, and there's...
I don't think they saw me.
I don't think they saw me, guys.
i'm trying to find any form of loot and it's not really been
successful i want to go fishing oh we all want something in
life can i loot this car does anyone oh nice there's i found
so i did it okay guys orange fans have cars hey guys over
here wait i could get us a car i'm picking out guys up with
a car a vehicle yeah don't worry i have a license no i
haven't driven a car in like a very long time i don't trust
that i'm concerned about that wait i do have a license i can
just i can just take the i might not have driven a car in a
while so uh whoa whoa there you go i guess yeah so i
accidentally damaged the car yay now i can just the car yeah
you can chill in the car don't pass up bro button up oh my
god all right wait can this car go through the water uh it
looks like a Humvee right it should be fine yeah it should
be fine all right you died i think he goes through the water
yeah see look at that see nothing to worry about all right i
gotta make sure supply station whoa whoa whoa oh my god
someone's got to fix these potholes i think that's the least
of their concerns at the moment no get some loot guys go
grab some guns oh that's loot go grab some guns oh wait
there is loot here thanks for dropping us off at soccer
practice no problem guys don't worry i do it for you guys
Mom, Winfield's bullying me.
The fucking man up.
Hit him back.
Like, bro, just hit him back.
Give him a lesson.
I won't, I won't, I won't look if you want to hit him.
I'm worried about you as a, as a parent.
Survival of the fittest, bro.
Gunshots northeast.
Just make him play Russian roulette, you know, and then you
get the whole neighborhood.
You worry about me being a parent.
Like, hey, hey, hey, this guy won.
You're gonna play your Russian prolete.
Do we fight that?
Yeah.
I ain't no pussy.
All I'm seeing is, like, in the wild, in the wild, it's all
about survival of the fittest.
Right.
The sibling that's the most fittest survive.
And if they don't, the mom eats the child.
Just eat them in the womb.
You know, like, pigs?
Okay, you know how they, like, cage up pigs because the
mommy pig can like will squish their children by rolling
them over so my parents so like don't fuck with me you
should be like those those twins that just like absorb their
sibling in the womb oh no i did oh the conjoined twin what
you already did
where the fuck are people i thought you said altair you said
there were people here i trusted you until i said nothing i
still was gonna pass up because i trusted your end up you
know what pass out axel pass out all right good night ladies
yeah we're gonna you're gonna be here to watch us win yeah
pass out after this
oh i left my car oh no what a shame
That's our car.
Oh, that's another...
I'm actually dying.
Holy shit.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, Axel.
There's still 21 more teams left.
Don't worry.
You're five.
It's just 21 more teams.
Oh, 69.
Nice.
I'm losing.
There's 69 players left.
Oh, people are dying so slow.
Oh, never mind.
67.
Haha, it's like seven.
Curse you, Doki Bird!
I'm trying to, I'm testing guns out.
Okay, we'll grab this.
Oops.
The two.
Wow, two are straight.
I'm just testing the gun out.
Oh, I know what gun I have.
I need to do some scouting.
Top 20!
Yay!
I thought it started with 20.
No.
It's like 21.
Wait.
Let's see.
You're so far ahead.
You're just getting.
Oh, okay.
We got this.
Still at 67, guys.
They know what they want.
They want to cringe and die.
Whoa.
Wait, what?
Where are you going to try to?
Oh, fuck.
Oh, my.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
You know, up there, you didn't tell me where you got shot
at.
Well that's the point of the scout.
I get shot first.
I was next.
Oh, no.
No.
I have something to do in 40 minutes.
No, you do.
No, you gotta play.
You gotta play another one.
And then Axel, Axel.
No, you too.
We enjoyed the game.
Axel, come on.
Axel, probably gonna end with if you leave though.
You can stay here for 40 minutes anyway.
You know?
Yeah, Axel.
Axel, we got in the game.
No, no, no, no, no.
Axel, you can't leave.
We got in the game though.
Axel, you can't leave me here alone with Doki.
She's gonna...
Wait, what the fuck?
No, no, wait, wait.
That's fake news.
You fell down those stairs yourself, buddy.
Axel, we can't end on a loss, bro.
Oh, yeah.
We've only been doing on a lot.
No, no, no, no.
We got six plays.
That's pretty good.
Yeah, we got top six.
Look, look.
Axel, Axel, Axel.
One more.
Last one, for real.
For real.
Yeah, see.
Win first set, we can win.
Win first, go lock.
Axel Look, look, Winfield said where you can- He's gonna
lock in now.
He's gonna lock in.
Axel, if you play one more, I'll open a case in
Counter-Strike.
Yeah, yeah, I'll buy a case.
Axel, I'll buy a case.
I'll buy- Don't you'll buy a case too.
I'll buy a case and unlock it.
And then I'll buy you a case too, Axel.
I'll buy you a case.
She's gonna buy you a case for free real estate.
Bro, it's free real estate.
You can get an life.
The only time I do not late, chapter is in- Okay, okay, go,
go.
He left the lobby.
You already left the lobby.
Wait, he left the lobby!
Oh, I'm too quick for you.
Oh, Axel.
Come on, bro.
LeBron would never have done a loss.
He would switch teams after that lows.
Axel.
Come on.
But Axel, you're just going to leave me here.
What if we win right now?
What if we win right now without you, Axel?
Then you would regret it all.
No, no, I won't.
It's just the game, guys.
You could have got your first win.
Look, we got levels.
60 we got a level 60 axel no no i'm dying so you gotta at
least watch us play this game axel just just be with us for
this one game just be with us no no come on be with us watch
this one game yeah yeah axel just be with us in spirit you
come on axel oh don't worry i'll share my screen axel don't
worry i'll share my screen soon here you go axel there you
go i got my screen share right now you're it's like you're
here it's like you're here axel it's like you're here with
us like you've been sharing my screen so you can just set up
for your stream while we're streaming yeah yeah yeah watch
us watch it you're gonna watch us win this we're gonna win
this for you axel we're gonna win this you guys ain't gonna
win this you're gonna win this for you you know you're gonna
regret this axel axel i hate you now i used to be your
biggest fan i'm She's my new best friend.
I know they're going to hate.
Cheepa left.
Wait, Cheepa left.
Wait, Cheepa.
Cheepa.
Wait, I parked this guy.
Oh, no.
Don't worry.
You're going to find us.
Well, ladies and gentlemen, thank you very much for watching
today.
No, no, no, Axel.
They're going to find us a new.
Wait, Axel, we have an open spot for you.
Axel, come back.
We have a fourth player.
Hey, hey, I believe in you.
I think this lobby's actually cooked.
No, no, no.
It's fine.
We're going to find another.
I believe in you guys' stuff.
Yeah.
yeah yeah we're gonna solo this lobby as three people we're
gonna three before everyone it's time my game crashed my my
game crashed oh it's just time it's just time guys look
jesus is saying yo amen motherfuckers but no more poor these
people yo i'll tear a screen share i'll tear a screen share
who watches spirit i'll tell her when it yo yeah what do you
mean we're watch it.
You're gonna watch it.
No, no, no, no, no, no, Axel, you and that we're gonna hope
gonna watch Altair.
It's okay.
We can't even get the players to this lobby though.
Where's when?
Where's Winfried?
Where did he go?
He left too?
It's just me.
Oh.
And Chad, look, you know what?
Maybe this is a good place to end.
I think Axel is right.
I told you guys the God, I could hear his voice maybe i'm
like ascending too high i'm flying too close to the sun it
is 1 a.m i should probably everyone's games crashed during
that queue so i think i think that was a sign it's a sign
see i can hear god whispering mees right now you're gonna
die soon you're gonna die soon be it he's telling me he's
just like freedom he doesn't deserve to suffer anymore yeah
let him go thank god god commands you to play one more i'm
an atheist so i don't believe in god okay how about how
about this how about this maybe in in return maybe we'll
have to schedule another stream at some other point yeah
we'll have another battlefield do some We should do
endurance stream for battlefield until we win one game.
Oh, hey, oh, hey, oh, no.
We got to do the Axel.
Come on.
Come on, Axel.
And then Tyre endurance stream.
Axel, come on.
Do you believe in us?
Guys, we're going to die.
We're going to die from it.
All right.
Okay.
It's like we get like RPR something.
So someone to carry us.
No, we could get Winfried again.
Yeah.
Winfried.
Okay.
I don't know.
Winfried didn't match.
But you guys are telling me you guys want to die from old
age.
Let's do it next week.
Let's do that.
Well, I'll think about.
think about it.
Hi, Axel.
You know, you wanna.
Enduring stream till we win.
We're going to be here forever.
I think actually if we get our PR, he's just going to carry
us.
I actually think we don't even have to play the game.
He's just here.
We shall see what happens.
Axel, look, it's a free win.
I'll tell you.
We will message Axel every day until he says yes.
Day 1000 of messaging.
I'm on it.
I'm on installing Discord.
Nope.
No.
And then we'll add him on Twitter.
And then we'll also add him on Twitter.
I will deactivate my Instagram, my Twitter, my Discord.
You can do that.
I'll be in your YouTube chat to ask you.
Oh, well, I won't stream then.
Thank you.
I'll tell you.
Okay.
We can do it.
You and I, we, we ask Axel every day until he says yes to
endurance stream until we win.
All right.
You do some pictures of your dog.
I'll send pictures of my cat.
and then we'll be like day one of asking axel if he can play
if he'll play battlefield with us i'll buy counter-shut case
and i'll be like hey axel this could be opened if only you
play with us yeah yeah hell no hell no i'll buy you a case
so you do it i don't need no case what do you need what do
you want axel we're here to negotiate i want freedom yeah
but then but then afterwards taste that good yeah come on
freedom will taste so good after you win a game how about
next week next week on on thursday how about thursday
Thursday 8 p.m eastern standard time yeah yeah yeah next
week thursday uh same time same place okay i'll see you guys
on thursday you fucking
guys so Thursday wait what time are we doing 5 p.m.
PSD or or 7 p.m.
PSD Axel can you wake up 5 p.m.
PSD on Thursday guys good night and then we're gonna do we
insurance until we win I'm gonna put it on my calendar Axel
you can't back out I'm gonna put it on my calendar I'm
putting on my calendar I'm gonna walk out every day trying
to like inhale people who are coughing like their lungs out
like before they say yes please
i'm gonna catch it i'm gonna catch it and go die children
all righty but thank you thank you for joining thank you
very much so for joining last minute thank you guys i had so
much fun everyone yeah yeah you should play some more games
more often yeah i'm sorry for not messaging often sorry no
it's okay me too don't worry i'm i've been really bad at it
too but don't on thursday we're gonna win that game we're
gonna win yeah i believe in us we're gonna win that game if
and not we're streaming to you twice next week because i
have the thing with battle oh that's true that's true yeah
and if not if we don't win at least we get to spend 12 hours
together guys that's the youtube limit oh yeah i don't get
to spend i'm going to hang myself on that no thank
all right guys so we we are a bit late for our membership
stream but don't worry i need like a 15 like a we'll start
at 10 30 guys just need a little bit of a buffer but i had a
great time i think great time sound guy i'm sorry that
altair was so loud i hope altair wasn't too loud everyone um
because i saw that sound guy kept asking me to lower altair
so i hope he was at a decent decent sound volume at the end
See, we'll see it We'll see Axel and Altair again Um On on
Thursday And we're gonna play until Until we win I believe
Look This was warm up Today was warm up We weren't locked in
And we were like Fucking around guys We were messing up But
of course we weren't gonna win Right away But but this time
This time This time next week next week next week it's it's
gonna change is it or we're gonna have a 12-hour bond it's
one or the other i think like whatever happens it'll be a
good time hey guys i'm sorry about to go like super quick
because i do have a member i was supposed to have a member
stream um like 12 minutes ago so but i do need a little bit
of a buffer uh but anyway guys i hope you guys have fun time
as always everybody stay hydrated pause check uh get them
around get that blood head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.